Hey of freaks, what's going on? Everybody?
This episode of the Joe Rogan
experience podcast is brought to you by
[inaudible] Dot Com
that's o. N N. I. T. A.
I'm wearing on a tee shirt today
cause I'm accompanied bitch.
Now actually a own a part of
this company. Um, what on it is,
is a human optimization website.
Our idea about on it is to sell
you all shit that we would use,
whether it's strength and
conditioning equipment,
whether it's supplements like the, the
best hemp protein powder we could find,
or whether it's raw foods like
walnut, almond, cashew butter,
or we have hemp force bars and we have
what we even sell this buffalo bar.
That's pretty bad as it's made the same
way the native Americans used to make it.
It's buffalo beat with buffalo
meat with cranberries and pepper.
It's delicious.
It's good for you.
It's better than a lot of shit you shoved
down your face when you're hungry for
snacks.
We sell strength and
conditioning equipment like
kettle bells and battle ropes
and we have the new,
a Zombie bells and primal bells.
Which of my personal favorite because
if you're going to work out and you want
motivation to, the two best motivations
are end of the world apocalypse scenario,
which the Zombie kettle bells represent.
Or you're about to get your
dick bit off by a chimpanzee.
That's what the Primal Bells, Remy
Warren knows the fuck I'm talking about.
He's camped in Africa. Ladies
and gentlemen, this is not
just a fucking visitor.
All right. That's uh, I was checking out
that a gorilla bell on their end. It's it.
You want one? I'll have it
sent to you. The thing is,
I don't even know if I'm strong
enough right now to lift that one,
but it's gonna motivate me to just,
I just want to crank. I will vote.
It's like he's just got that
furrowed brow. The grill.
It doesn't have to just be angry.
He's just bad ass, you know? Yeah.
The chimp has to show his teeth and
he'd pull it, pull up the image.
It's not working. Something's
wrong. Um, the, uh,
the chimpanzee looks all angry, but the
grill was like, Bitch, oh, goody. Oh Wow.
Look at that girl.
Doesn't need to show no teeth.
All those are a completely
three d balanced as well.
We made sure that when we made these,
these are not just ornaments,
they're beautiful to look at,
but there are a hundred percent functional
as far as a kettle bells as far as
like the balance of it,
the weight,
you have to shift it so that you know
you don't want the face slamming in your
forum. You want the round part
in the back, but other than that,
easy to use and they will last fucking
forever. Those bitches are solid metal.
They will last forever and if you're
going to get into kettlebell workouts,
I suggest very strongly
that if you can afford it,
go to someone who knows what they're
doing and take a private lesson.
Go to like any,
there's a lot of gyms that show
that have a kettlebell instructors,
they do crossfit and
things along those lines.
They'll be able to show you just the
basic movements and hopefully they'll let
you film it with your phone or
something like that or not. If not,
if you can't afford that, go to youtube.
There's many, many instructional videos,
but do it correctly. Do it slowly.
Pay attention to your form.
Do lightweights at first,
very important.
You'd be amazed at what a good workout
you can get from a 35 pound kettle bell,
the extreme kettlebell cardio
workout DVD that we sell on the site.
I use that with one 35 pound kettle
bell and it's a motherfucker you,
you will enjoy the shit out of.
It incorporates a lot of body weight
exercises as well along with that 35 pound
kettle bell and it is a fucking
hard exploder go to on it.
Oh and it used the code name Brogan and
save 10% off any and all supplements.
We also have a new program. Uh,
you can learn about it on, on it,
the stay on it program.
We've,
we can get all the supplements that
you enjoy and use shipped to you
automatically each month at the lowest
price. Guaranteed. That's o. N N.
I t again,
use the codeword Rogan and save 10% off.
Any of the supplements were
also brought to you by Lumosity.
Lumosity is a website that essentially
it's like a gym for your brain.
That's how it's set up.
It's set up to give you things to do that
are exciting and that can enhance and
work on various aspects of cognitive
function. Like your memory.
There's all these different settings.
If you go to lumosity.com you can check
it out. It's really interesting. Um,
I like it cause they're like games and uh,
when you go there,
like you click the get started now button,
it immediately takes you this
thing that asks you about memory.
Select all aspects of your
member that you want to train.
Things like recalling
the location of objects,
remembering the names after
the first introduction, uh,
learning new subjects and then
you'll move from that onto attention.
Then moved from that on to speed and
they'll build you a personalized training
program. I think that's pretty
cool. Um, it's also, it's fun.
It's like it's an easy thing to do.
That's fun. That's good for your brain.
It's healthy.
Just like your body needs to exercise
in order to work at maximum efficiency.
He brain needs to too. They have
them set up. Uh, so there's a,
there's an app so you
could play it on your iPad,
your iPhone with the free
Lumosity APP. Uh, have fun.
Workout your brain and make Lumosity
a part of your everyday routine.
You don't be fucks. You know, you
need it. Stop playing, man. Go there.
Go to lumosity.com/joe.
That's lumosity.com l m o s,
I t y.com/joe.
Click the start training button
and start playing your first game,
lumosity.com/joe.
We're also brought to you
by squarespace.com and
if you listen to our last
podcast, you realize that Squarespace
is hosting a, a contest. Now. Uh,
it goes on. I think this
is the last week, right?
It doesn't like January
17th. I think it ends. Um,
spear Squarespace is the
easiest way to make a website.
Excuse me.
If you thought about hiring somebody,
like hiring a website company to design
your website, that shit is expensive.
It takes a long time.
Sometimes it's annoying.
You can do it yourself.
It used to be that it was a fun,
I mean you could always do it yourself.
If you wanted to learn html or you wanted
to learn how to use Dreamweaver or all
these different various
website creating softwares,
but you don't have to do that anymore.
It's so simple.
A dummy like me can make a website,
a sweet website,
but just point and click.
Drag and drop is easy as using the
normal functions on your computer and you
could set up a website that
you could sell things from.
You could easily set up ecommerce there.
They have it set up so that you can
sell things there. You can down,
you could have music downloads,
you could sell music if you're a musician.
It's a really easy and sweet way to
set up in an all in one platform,
your own website. It makes the
work on I iPhones, android,
windows, apple, all that shit.
For a free trial and 10%
off your first purchase.
Go to squarespace.com and enter
the code Joe and the number one,
that's squarespace.com Joe.
And the number one that count,
you know one is for January,
it's all one word, Joe one. Um,
so after you've done this, uh, if
you want to enter into the contest,
you build a website and tweak the
website to Hashtag j r e Squarespace.
That's just Hashtag jre Squarespace
one word. Before January 17th,
I will pick four winners who have
designed the most beautifully designed and
lovely websites and uh,
Squarespace.
We'll give these winners a free year of
Squarespace and we'll send these winters
a swag bag with items like Squarespace,
apple keyboard,
a tee shirt, mole skin, and
more. So go to squarespace.com.
Use the code word Joe one to build a
website and then tweet your new site to
Hashtag j r e Squarespace.
All right, that's it.
You're Fox. Keep the music. Dan
Dodi's here. Remy warrants here.
Let's get busy.
The Joe Rogan experience by day
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day
because of two.
These two men that are here today,
one of them is responsible for
turning me into a hunting nut.
Dan Dodi was a big part of that.
The experience of going to
Montana and a Ramey warrant.
If you've ever watched
any of the shows a on the,
is it the sportsmans channel yet? Well,
the meat eaters on the sportsman's,
I've done some stuff with Steve and then
a solo hundred is on outdoor checks.
On the outdoor channel. Yeah.
There's three channels on, uh,
on direct TV that are pretty much all
hunting and fishing. What's the third one?
I don't know. It's like your suit
and it's so every time I tuned in,
if I'm looking for like my a dressing
room this weekend I was in Phoenix doing
stand up and we just had hunting shows
on it. Dressing room all the time.
I'm fucking bananas. I'm not really
doing, you've got a real frog.
Watch them all the time.
Oh Dude, I'm sick. And you
don't really care what it is.
You Watch, whatever. Um, they're
terrible. A lot of them are awful.
I was telling you guys before that there
was one that was watching where a kid
was getting interviewed and he had his
hand up to block the sun as the cameras
interviewing him. And
he's like, well, you know,
we're going to go out today and
hopefully we'll be successful. And like,
what do you know?
There's a lot.
There's a fucking Sun's
glaring in this kid's face.
Can you move the camera
can moved the couch?
Like what the fuck are you guys doing?
And it's one of the things that I really
did appreciate about your show, um,
meat eater that you produce is
that it's just so much better shot.
It's so much more interesting. The
narration is, is, uh, it's articulate.
It's fascinating. It's introspective,
you know, it's the, it's a full picture.
It's a great show. And I was trying
to show this to my wife the other day.
I'm like,
this fucking show is too good to just
be tucked away on a hunting channel
because the,
the hunting channel programs for the most
part don't attract the regular folks.
But I really think that show was so
well made that it could be on the travel
channel or you know,
discovery. It's a great show.
She thinks I'm fucking crazy.
She doesn't want to talk to me.
He says what I said in front of the
couch watching animals die. You know,
especially like yesterday was a rough
one because I was watching the lion hunt
that I was telling you about.
Pig Man was a shooting lions with a
bow and Arrow and these lines and just
laying there sleeping and he's creeping
up on him and pumps an hour to their
heart and she's like, I
gotta go. I can't watch this.
Yes. So just shows like that.
You know, the normal guy gone,
oh I'm going to check this out.
And then they turn on one
of those shows are like,
what the hell is going on here? You know?
But then comes along guy like Dan Dodi,
we just make some awesome stuff that can
be anywhere and you know what I mean?
You can find these really good shows on
there as well that are full of adventure
and just being out there being a man,
you know, it's no way I can sit here.
I can't take credit for that shit.
There's no, there's no credit for it,
but you are a part of it.
Sure, sure. Yeah. Yeah. But
there's a huge like very crew,
very creative, very like
fantastic team. That makes sense.
Yes.
That's a very important thing.
And it's the you that's shows how humble
you are, that you brought that up,
that that is a very important aspect
of anything that comes out. Well,
there's a team behind it and
especially a big time TV show.
Here's a fucking team of
people behind the scenes
and, and we give a shit.
And Steve, you know, has an
incredibly intelligent way to,
to do what he does and to
talk about what he does.
And we have people who can edit and shoot
and run the show. And it's just, it's,
it's a big deal. And,
and having, uh, you know,
bringing grammy out there who has
been a perfect fit for us too. It's,
I think I can't watch hunting TV. I can
barely watch our show. I love our show.
I can barely watch our show,
but I really,
I could not sit like you
and watch haunting TV in
general. I just can't do it.
I watch it all the time,
but I'm obsessed right now with hunting.
Hopefully it'll calm down a little bit.
No, I'm obsessed. I was
like born into it and I'm,
I'm more obsessed now than I was when I
first got into it. How old do you know?
I'm 28 now. And you've been hunting
your entire life? Yeah, I mean,
I don't remember a time where it
wasn't hunting. You know, I think like,
I remember a birthday party when
I was a kid, you know, and uh,
had to be like first grade
and my, you know, got a,
some kind of pellet gun or whatever,
you know,
we set up this little thing
in the backyard, just all
these balloons and targets.
And I was
a kid when I was in first grade. Man, I
just sit there, pow, POW, POW, POW, pow,
all day long.
Just just shooting and stocking
things and just where did you grow up?
I grew up in Reno, Nevada. Oh
Wow. Yeah. Got To have a gun.
If you live in Reno. Yeah.
People. Yeah. Just for the people you have
to hunt. Exactly. I mean, Johnny Cash,
he shot a guy in Reno, right?
That's right. Just to watch him die.
I mean it shows you
what kind of an effect that fucking town.
Yeah. I first found out about you
because of meat eater. Um, the uh,
episode where you guys a while
there was a couple of them.
You went on one of them when you
went to New Zealand, right? Yeah.
And then there was another,
was that the one where you had to travel
that crazy fucking river that we shut
that Steve shot that shammy across the
river in the hand across it. And I was,
I was pretty Wally man.
That was bad ass moments on our show.
And that wasn't a bullshit fake.
Dow was nothing was that
iceberg was coming down to
and we have that line across
there and we're all looking
at each other like, yeah,
we may film someone die here today.
This is part of my duties to is I'm kind
of like the medical guy or officer on
the,
on the crew too.
I was scared shitless that day and
Steve doesn't have a whole lot of fear.
Ramey doesn't have much
fear in that's fine.
But to manage that shit in the field,
that was sketchy man. That was like,
but then the,
the product of that,
that sequence of that
actual action in the moment,
to me that's the most exciting,
well it's so exciting and they
didn't play it up with them.
Some stupid cliffhanger at the
like, you know, like oh Jesus,
like pretending slips a little
bit. Yeah. There was none of that.
It was just the drama of the real
situation of trying to cross a freezing
glacial river was more than enough.
It was amazing. It was fucking scary.
That's an amazing day. Right? I mean,
you know, like before, I mean we,
we kind of had to think about this,
you know,
and I stuck my hand in there and we
timed how long before your joints stop
moving, you know, and it was like 60
seconds and that water, you're done.
You are gone. Ice Water. Literally I just,
just warming up to not the ice anymore.
God Damn. And then the next day we get
up and climbed, climbed up a, you know,
3000 feet up mountain almost slipped
off a cliff for the integrity of it.
Your show. The fact that I know when
I watched that, that all this is real.
When we did that thing in Montana and when
we win a mule deer hunting, there was,
there was no bullshit. There was no faking
anything. There's no fake scenarios.
There's a show that I really love.
It's a Alaska, the last frontier,
but I watched it the other
day and they, uh, they're,
they're fly fishing and in
the middle of fishing, uh,
all of a sudden a bear shows up and the
bears eating some salmon and they're
like, Oh shit, a bears here.
We've gotta get Outta here.
And then I look at the salmon and the fuck
Hammond's been filleted.
They've taken the filets off the salmon
and through the carcasses out for the
bear, they baited this fucking bear
to come up to the river. And I'm like,
God damn it. You ran out of
shit. That's interesting. Yeah.
I can't think at first they were
just all homesteading and shit,
but then now they got to fake some,
some,
some Hollywood producer Dick wads
can get ahold of it and try to fake
thanks Vic. They underestimate
the intelligence of the
average American viewer,
man.
They,
it's like almost insulting to watch them
this stuff and say it's some guy that's
never seen a salmon in his life,
thinks is a good idea to do that and
they think that nobody's going to know.
Yeah. Okay. It's me clean
filet on both sides.
I mean just like so obvious at this
thing came out of a cooler and somewhat
chucked it and Q big foot.
Yeah.
I think they underestimate part of
America's intelligence and then they
perfectly nail a lot of hunger, America's
intelligence because people eat it up.
You guys were, the first time I found
out about duck dynasty were on that trip.
You were goofing on it.
You and Steve were going back and forth
goofing on duck dive and see like you
done lost your redneck.
I lost my red neck and I was like,
what is this fucking show?
And you're like,
this is unbelievably stupid show that's
so obviously fake about these guys that
have done, which then became
the biggest show on TV. Dude,
it crushed our show are my Scifi
show that I was doing for awhile.
When I first started doing it,
the ratings were excellent and then we
went up against duck dynasty and got
stopped.
Everybody,
it was like the highest rated premier
ever in cable TV history for a show like
that. My Dad, my dad, just fucking love.
Especially now that the god done came
out and stood up for heterosexual.
You know what a man can
have his own opinion. Yeah.
I think a man's ass as a shitty choices.
Well everybody gets all fucking
crazy and riled up. Goddamn,
you taken away their first amendment
rights. How did that resolve?
They just fucking, they backed off.
I mean I think it's a and e right?
Cause that what? It was just hilarious.
Right? And they used to be like old plays,
these masterpiece theater and Shit,
you know?
And now it's this fucking fake show about
these guys who just grew their beard
out only for this show. Have you ever
see those photos of them? No. Oh,
it came out since the show that they
didn't use to look like that at all.
They would normal guys, like they
had like a regular, you know,
facial hair grew it all out for the show.
So they started on a hunting channel.
They started with duck commander. Right.
I think. Right. So like
when I was a kid, man,
duck commander videos were the
shit. I mean, it was like, you know,
Phil Roberts,
you'd be out there and his duck blind
and he would say some funny stuff.
And I'm like,
I literally learned how to call ducks
from duck commander videos like as a kid,
you know, so like you see like, you know,
and I don't know how many other
people have had that experience,
but nobody ever taught me how to duck
hunt, you know? And so I was like, I was,
I was like any kind of hunting I could do,
I wanted to do.
So I would teach myself whatever
I would get books. Oh yeah, yeah.
This is what they looked like. And
this is all those guys. No Shit. Yes,
that's them. Why do we have
one with a duck fly through?
Look at, it's crazy. They're
like golfers, they like suburban,
like gated
community golfers. I Dunno, I don't know
that much about, I don't know either.
But I mean, who cares? I mean like
they're just selling duck blinds.
And my point was that, um, you guys
don't do any fake shit, you know, and,
and, and, and not doing fake shit. It's
still a really fucking exciting show.
Steve sent me the one from this upcoming
season where it gets charged by the
Moose. Did you see that? Fuck yeah,
I did. I saw it five times. No,
isn't it that fucking moment, man. That's
crazy. That's awesome. He got fucking,
he took a brisket shot and when
I say anything I, you know,
I don't want to give it away because a,
I don't want to spoil the drama
when it comes on television.
What I've said has not spoiled
at all though. Holy Shit.
It's a great fucking show.
It's not just a hunting show.
It's a great show and that's what I was
trying to convince my wife. I'm like,
this is a good fucking show.
She's like, okay, crazy.
Whatever most people do once they do
see it though, that they'll get it,
they'll get it. They'll understand
that it's not, I mean there's,
there's so much explicit sort of
conversation about what we're doing. It's,
it makes sense. It's clear. When we were
in Wisconsin freeze and our dicks off,
we were in that, that deer
blind. It was cold as fuck.
And Dan Dodi steps outside of the blind
and he's taking all these crazy shots.
And I was thinking, man,
you fucking work hard dude.
You guys work hard everywhere you and
moe and everyone in that showed that is a
fucking 24 hour day job
too because there's,
you don't get off at nine o'clock in
the night, you know, boy, long day.
But at least I go back to my
hotel room to fuck you do,
you're sleeping on the ground or in the
basement or in the basement at Doug,
her aunt's house. You know, in Wisconsin,
it's cold as fuck up there too. Shit.
I think I go pretty hard, you know, and
then these guys come to New Zealand,
you've got, oh film crews coming. This
is my first dealing with them, you know,
and New Zealand's not for pussies,
man.
It's like the roughest place
on the planet. So they told me,
there's few film crews come
in and I'm like, Oh God.
Well I don't know how this is gonna work
and these dudes are running around the
truck. And I'm like, I thought I went
pretty good. And if I put a gps on them,
they hung like a bird dog out in front of
you, up, back, back in, up the mountain,
down the mountain. You're like, holy.
Well,
when we were in Montana,
we were going through the bad
lands and it's high altitude.
It's really cold and it's
exhausting because it's all mud.
You're walking through the mud.
These guys are running in front of us.
Like I'm exhausted just from hiking.
They're running in front of
us to film us being exhausted,
and you guys probably put out an extra
40% more calories in anybody because
you're also carrying this giant ass
fucking camera up this mountain.
Like all I have, the rifle at
least is strapped to my shoulders.
I'm moving my arms and shit.
You guys have to carry this fucking thing.
I'm proud of my one handed abilities.
I learned, I learned this all from moe,
like he and his ethic and his way is
why the show is what it is and why I
learned I didn't know
how to shoot a camera for
[inaudible]. Who's the director?
I'm the director now.
He was a director. He's,
he's not doing a whole lot with media.
You meat eater anymore. But um, yeah,
I didn't, he taught me every
God damn thing. I know.
I didn't know a thing about TV.
About shooting.
Yeah. Mo goes to the gym,
it puts a big pack on,
filled with shit and gets on a
stair climber to prepare for work.
Yeah.
Says the best shape he was ever in was
from surfing and then he went out and
kicked Steve's ass in the field.
He was able to run laps around Steve,
but it was surfing. Really. I got him
to that shape. That's interesting.
I wouldn't feel like surfing would
be that exhaustive. Oh Man. Yeah.
I tried to get, I went surfing
one time with my brother and uh,
in the Dominican Republic. You know
what I'm thinking? Like, oh yeah,
this can't be that,
that bad.
I was so gassed by the time I got out
to catch a wave. I was like, screw this.
I'm going back just from the oven. Yeah,
yeah. No, just trying to paddle out there,
man. If you see that does make sense. I
was just thinking of the surface itself.
I didn't take into account
the swimming out to you.
You use all those muscles
like every muscle,
you know you're trying to stay bowel. This
is live on the way. Yeah. Oh, everything.
It's, yeah. Yeah, I would imagine. Well,
I was surprised at how fucking
hard the hiking was in Montana.
That was the one thing that really shocked
me because I was in pretty good shape
when I went there too.
Luckily because I was thinking like
as we're going up to sale, it's like,
what if I was a fuck head and I did.
It didn't work out all the time or I
drank a lot or something like that.
This is fucking hardcore shit.
You did well calendered while he,
both of you both just showed up. We got
lucky. We got lucky that we were in shape.
You know, like that you couldn't do
that if he wasn't, we weren't in shape.
It's fucking hard. Couldn't hunt like
right now and you're like, Steve,
you couldn't hunt. We Hunt. I mean most
people don't hunt that way. As you know,
as you've sort of seen that it's not,
not everybody.
I've taken a lot of dudes and uh,
a lot of them puke the first day
just on that just die, just die.
And well Steve was telling about these
big power lifted guys that he took out,
you know, that there were
saying, uh, you know, you guys,
you guys are in good shape.
Yeah,
we're in good shape.
He goes 30 minutes in their red in the
face and throwing up and there's like a
huge difference between being,
he'll,
he'll fit and fit for other things
because like I've been doing this my whole
life. I do it. She had
about 200 more days a year.
Like a couple of years ago. I was 324
days in the Bush, you know, so it's like,
it's nothing, it's just
another day, you know,
but you build up this kind
of fitness, you know, for,
for going up hill. I'm good at
going up hill flat. Don't like,
it's like muscle memory uphill works every
time. You have to do it all the time.
That's the case with everything.
Martial arts,
the more you get efficiency of movement,
your body understands that movement
can do it over and over again.
Then you have this massive endurance
in it. Exactly. You know like legs is,
especially when you think about like
how ridiculous it is that your legs just
carry around all day and not under
normal circumstances. Never get tired.
Your legs, you walk to work, you'd sit
down, you'd walk around the office,
there's no problem. Think about if you
had a carry 120 pounds with your arms,
you know it's ridiculous just
carrying it with your arms.
Forget about like moving constantly
and shifting weight. You'd do.
Your legs can do some pretty amazing
things, which is why kickboxing,
it's a great way to fight cause your,
your legs can do shit that your
upper body could just never do.
The amount of force that you can generate.
What do you think the ratio is in
force from your leg to your arm?
It's ridiculous. It's
off the charts. Yeah.
Several times 20 maybe if it
spends on what kind of kick,
but like a spinning back kick.
If you ever seen someone who
really knows how to kick a bag,
kick a bag with like a turning side kick
or spending back in, it goes flying.
I have 150 pound bag and it
launches through the air.
I can't do that with a punch.
If you kick somebody like that,
it's like hitting them with a car.
They just go flying.
You could just do shit with your legs.
You could never do with your arms.
Think about it like all your weights in
the foot. That spinning too. When you're,
when you're punching, you know both feet
are planted. You know you're pushing,
you're using momentum, but you're
like, when you're spinning around,
you throw every bit of weight
into that foot is deadly.
It's also the size of your feet so
much bigger than the size of your hand.
The bigger hands are the hardy
you can punch and the big,
it's way bigger than your fucking hand.
It's heavier bone.
Think about how much you
can hit with your heel.
We're never bothers your heel at all.
You could run on concrete with your
heel and literally get away with it.
You couldn't punch concrete once,
you know,
so the amount of force that
you could generate with your,
your legs and your feet,
it's crazy.
It's just a little more difficult to
do because you're balancing on one leg,
it's a little slower because the bones
are heavier, but God damn when it lands,
it's ridiculous.
The amount of head kicks that land in
in the UFC and wound up being knockouts,
it's pretty fucking high.
He kicked somebody in the
head. It's usually not good,
but the price, it was just
still so very surprising to me.
The endurance that you
need to just walk up hills,
you need some serious and endurance.
And Dan was telling me that you,
you did some crazy veal Max
test and wound up like, uh,
like an elite endurance athletes.
Yeah. So we did this, uh,
for actually this new show that, uh,
we'll probably end up talking about here.
We did this vo two Max test, which for
people that don't know what that is,
it measures your endurance capability.
So it's a,
it's essentially where at what
point your body goes anaerobic,
how much oxygen you take in
and then carbon dioxide out.
And then what happens is your body,
your muscles work on oxygen.
So once that your, your muscles
can't take in any more oxygen,
your body goes anaerobic, your endurance
is over, you know, you get gas,
do you get hit? You're done. So we,
uh, we did this vo two Max test,
right? And, uh, essentially
coming back, I mean the average,
what's an average guy like 60? No,
not even I think like 40, 40. Yeah.
So like an average guy, he's about 45. Um,
I had a vo two Max test at
4,500 feet elevation of 83.6.
So, and, and comparing that
maybe television, that might
have been like around 86,
87. Um, but so like got
people listening. Well, 86,
87 was that so a Lance Armstrong when he
was blood doping had a vo two Max test
done and it was around,
what was it, 84 84?
I think so.
I mean, think about it.
Like Lance Armstrong,
we know him as he's done some
serious endurance shit, you know,
and here's a guy myself,
this just out there every day hiking up.
I mean I'm,
I'm hiking up monster mountains.
I've got a 40 pound pack on,
on average.
And then when I'm packing stuff out,
it might be my bodyweight, you know,
through these mountains. But I'm body
weight on top of that. Uh, yeah, like,
like, uh, you know, I say I
maxed my pack out about 150,
hundred 70 pounds and I weigh about 100
and 5,070 pounds somewhere in there,
you know, so I mean, you're
really carrying a lot of
weight going up hill mostly,
you know, up and down obviously. And uh,
just doing it every day, day in, day out.
It's like there's no better type of
endurance training you think about it.
I mean, I mean, I normally do
about 20 miles a day and, uh,
a lot of elevation gain. I did
just one year, it wasn't my,
my biggest year is just more of
an average year. I tracked my, um,
elevation gain and within one season I
would have done enough vertical up to
climb Everest 16 times.
That's not that,
that's not the miles, that's just
straight elevation gain. That's, you know,
I mean thousands of miles every year.
You know, I think my largest year,
I've estimated that it probably be like
summiting Everest 60 times something
like that. Times. Yeah. It's
just so much. I mean, you know,
you go do 3000 feet a day and you're
doing it for 300 days and you just starts
adding up. You know, you just
see that chart. Did you see that?
The excellent category for 18 to 26
year old males was 60 in the highest.
Pulled that up. So this meaty something
we're talking fucking free. It's crazy.
Like free, not just high, but the dudes
that administered, I mean this was like,
people might come and look, oh, was
it a real, no, this was a legit test.
These guys do, you know,
professional athletes, everything.
And the guy that had done it, rob, I
mean, he looked at me and he's like,
I've been doing this for 24 years. Highest
I've ever seen was a 74. He's like,
this is nuts, you know? And
he kind of like, he's like,
oh, you're a hunter, you know?
And it kind of came in there.
I just kind of like, you know,
came in there and low ball them. I was
like, do you, do you work out much?
I was like, no, I mean at work, you
know, you don't really work out. Nah.
You know what I mean? Climb
up hills was shut on your
face. Yeah. I mean when, when,
uh, when it's like my off
what I call my off season,
it's any day that I'm not out
out in the woods, um, you know,
I'll do workouts because otherwise I
just get lazy, lethargic, you know,
placed and like, what do you do for a
workout if you're, if you're not on, oh,
I mean, it could be. I like to
run. I mean, I don't like to run,
I don't think anyone likes to run.
If they tell you that they're lying.
But I think they like me. I
mean I like, I like to run,
I guess you know, for as
much as you like running. Um,
I'll do just like body weight stuff.
Yeah. Pull up sips. Cause the thing,
the thing that I've learned
for me is I'm just, my body
type is endurance. That's it. I'm built
for endurance. So for me to go do sit ups,
I'll be there all day. Like
it doesn't do shit, you know,
it's just so I would have to, I would
have to change my, cause I went to, um,
my buddy Joe did well, he does like
physical fitness training, nutrition,
everything. I was like, man, I want to
get big. And so he's like, all right,
let's do some stuff. And he's
like, dude, for you to get big,
you're going to have to
change your complete.
Like we have to completely change your
muscles from these endurance muscles to
muscles that are just like power.
Yeah.
But you're so young and in
such good shape. I don't
think it would be that hard.
The real issue with it is you run the
risk of being injured because if you want
to get big,
you have to do power lifting stuff like
you have to do dead lifts and squats.
And the only way to really get big is you
got to start doing like sets of three.
Yeah, three reps Max. And you
know, when you get to that third,
ah,
when you do that, man, you're, there's,
everything's getting stressed to its
limit and so your body starts freaking out
and goes, we gotta fucking get bigger.
And then if you're shoveling protein down,
you're facing, by the way, farting up a
fucking horrendous storm during the day.
Why? Because you're, you're going
to take in too much protein.
Your body sound not going to
know what to do with a lot of it.
If you want to really do it right,
you almost have to overload your system.
You can,
I mean there's,
there's a lot of different schools of
thought when it comes to getting big,
but almost universally they agree that
you need a high level of protein in your
body. And if you're eating like, you know,
you're drinking like whey
protein and all that,
you just get out far all the time.
My friend Tate,
when Tate was, uh, when he was really big,
when he's competing on
the ultimate fighter,
it was just constantly pounding
protein bars and him and he would fart.
It was so bad that like people
would run out of a room.
I mean, I'm not kidding.
They wouldn't run away.
He farted once in the lobby of the comedy
store in La Jolla and people started
screaming. He was screaming like, my God,
what the fuck is that?
It's just impacted bowels filled with
undigested protein meeting digestive
enzymes and acids. Yes. No Fun. No,
just open the gates of hell.
Yeah.
I'm just going to stick to the hiking,
I think. Yeah. For you to get bigger,
you'd have to do some serious, uh, like
you'd have to lift some serious weights,
especially if you can carry a pack that,
that much that heavy all the time.
You would have to go heavy.
You would have to be doing like 315
pound squats and things like that.
Then you'd be working with an Arrow.
Oh yeah. That all bulky. UDB Yup. Yeah.
It's like uh, you know, it's, it's
all weight to leg ratio in my opinion.
It's like my legs can carry a lot of
weight but my body's like my upper body
real light, you know, so I, I trade in
that wait and throw something in my pack.
But if your legs are that strong a
guarantee, your arms would adapt.
If you force your arms to do things at
a lot of chin ups or things along those
lines, I bet you'd fucking be able to
bang off 20 of them. Cause if you're in
that kind of shape,
dude that's a huge advantage.
If you ever wanted to
do Jujitsu. Yeah. Okay.
I wanted to learn a martial art Jiu Jitsu.
One of the big things about Jujitsu is
just getting tired cause you know you're
straining against another grown man is
trying to kill you. I know it's, it's,
it's exhausting.
And one of the big things that Jujitsu
guys like universally try to figure out
is what's the best kind of
strength and conditioning workout.
Like a lot of the guys run dunes.
That's a big one. Sand Dunes.
I've been curious about Jujitsu.
I did. Taekwondo is a kid.
Grammy did taekwondo for a long time.
Taekwondo for a long time. My roommate,
Jake's like big. And did you just see
now he went into over to Thailand,
did some movie tie in. You
know, so I've been like a,
I think that's going to be my end too.
I want to do it. You live in Reno? Yeah.
Yeah. I'll find your school. I know,
I know. It's gotta be one near there.
I just got my uh, nephew into
it. They didn't have you.
Well as you do jet is that practice that
um, well I started out in taekwondo.
I used to teach tok windows.
He did was open champion and one in the
Massachusetts state title four years in
a row before I ever became a comedian.
That's why it's do I used
to teach tok window for a
living. Oh Huh. Yeah. And then,
uh,
I didn't get into Jujitsu,
so till [inaudible] 96 I found out
about the UFC and then I started in La.
It's a 96 window instructor when
I was a kid was like my, uh,
I dunno my gateway into becoming
a real human. I think you really,
he was a good guy. Mine as well. Yeah.
It'd be a becoming a man dealing with
typical chits. Samia yeah, martial arts,
you know,
there's a lot of goofiness to martial
arts is a lot of sort of cult stuff.
You know, a lot of times it can get
really weird, especially if the,
the instructor winds up being abusive,
you know, there was always this,
this weirdness of this one
guy who was the, you know,
the leader that everyone was terrified
of and thought he was just this great
master that could kill anyone on the
planet. Dude, if you knew about my master,
if he got in the UFC, it
would be two deadly. You know,
there's always that, but no,
that's interesting actually.
So the same guy who was so good for
me ended up marrying one of his young
students. How old? How old was she?
I think she was 17 Oh, Jesus Christ.
And he was in his deep thirties,
late twenties. That's not Tampa.
What belt was she?
Wicked black belt.
We tested for our black belts together.
Jay. Yeah, Jay, you'd be great at Jujitsu.
It just do it if you want to do it.
It's great martial art.
It's to me the best martial art because
you can go full blast and you don't have
to worry about brain trauma.
You know,
the thing about kickboxing is you can
only sparse so much [inaudible] just the
little sparring, just little thumps,
you know, just not even full blast,
just getting hit with jabs and stuff.
Your,
your head gets rattled and
that's all that accumulates.
The acumen of damage inside your brain.
It's just not good.
My grandpa was a professional
boxer and uh, yeah,
I mean his end of life wasn't as
good as this beginning of life.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean,
by the time it was over is my dad and me
and probably the only guys that he even
knew the name of half the
time. But uh, I have, uh,
friends that I started out with that have
brain damage now and I knew them when
I didn't.
I knew them when they were fine.
And now if I go back to Boston
and I see him, I talk to them. I
see it, I see it there. They're
always drunk. That's what it's like.
It's like always being drunk. Yep. Hello
Kitty. Is Everything good out there?
You know, it was, uh, July. Get out there
is to give everything good out there.
So the hell repeat stories.
Like they'll just tell you a story and
then repeat it just a minute later and
then try it again like a minute
after that. It's, it's sad.
It's sad when you remember how a guy used
to be fine and you're the same age as
him and you look at them and you're
like, oh fuck. Like this is what happens.
This is unavoidable. Then you get hit in
the head too many times is what happens,
but you don't get that in Jujitsu.
But you would have a giant advantage dude.
Then when you have fucking
great endurance to man,
you'd have a giant and you're a big guy.
The endurance that you have is
unusual for a guy's biggest heaviest.
Well, that's the thing is that my
body puts on muscle very, very easily,
but I tend to have a more
endurance lifestyle. So my buddies,
I was a little confused. It's like
what the fuck are you doing man? Yeah.
You Dad's a stocky fella as well and a
hell of a fucking cook. Yes, isn't it?
Oh Dude, it's dad hooked us up when we're
in Wisconsin. It a deer camp is dabs.
The chef. Oh Dude. He
cooked everything man.
He made Chili and it was really good food.
Halibut,
Sufi Che I think to doesn't everything
tastes better after hunting day?
Yes. I mean, yeah, you just
use up everything and you,
no matter what you put,
you could put it like a
nasty Bologna Sandwich.
I've enjoyed more Bologna sandwiches
out hunting. I Hate Bologna.
Never equaling eight dear heart.
Um, the of a deer that I shot,
we ate it. Maybe what, two hours
later? Yeah. If even if even two hours,
it was amazing. Just fresh off the
frying pan, crackle, boom. Like that.
It doesn't get any fresh and delicious
fresh meat. The hearts like the best.
It's the most tender out of a fresh kill
is the heart and you wouldn't think it,
you know, but it's actually
like compared to other organs,
you know the heart's a muscle
and a half of what happens.
Like when you shoot your deer rigor comes
into the animal and that's why right
off the bat,
you know that back stake might be a little
chewy and then you let it, you know,
wait a week or whatever and
what's happening is that
rigorous breaking down and
it's actually, you know the meats
almost decomposing over time.
That's when you get those like dry age
steaks. You're just eating rotten meat.
So good.
But I don't take that much time for the
rigor to break down eating so much fresh
meat on mediator.
Now I have a taste for freshmen to have
a taste for that sort of copper metallic
confession closer to your face.
Yeah.
I have a taste for fresh meat that
almost metal taste and I do not like aged
meat. I don't either. I'm 100% with you.
I don't need age meat anymore unless
I have to. If I'm at a restaurant,
somebody foolish of me. But, um, if I
eat beef, I try to eat a, there's a,
I have a ranch that I buy from that's
a near me that's 100% grass fed.
They don't, they don't supplement with
corn at all. And it's a dark red meat.
It's like a game meat. It's weird.
It's like the cattle looks different.
It's less fat on it. It looks
natural. Not supposed to,
but the grossest thing is when you
go to the butcher and you see the dry
age situation, you see what
they're doing. You're like,
the fuck are you doing that mean
you're ruining a big percentage of it,
first of all, because the outside, they
cut it off that rotten brown shit. Yup.
It's fucked. Yeah. I don't,
you know, I'm not like,
I'm Kinda guy that I eat while I
eat stuff. I kill, I eat game meat,
I eat wild meat.
And when you eat that,
like it's hard to explain to somebody
that doesn't because when you eat that,
it feels like food in your body.
Like you feel regenerated if feels good.
You know,
it's like I eat a lot of elk
because I guide hunters for elk.
And that's one thing that I always
hunt and an elk stake is red meat,
but it has less cholesterol than
skinless chicken. Wow. So people,
so if your doctor is like no, no
red meat. No, it's not no red meat.
It's no weird human mutated me,
which would be like corn fed,
marbled beef. I uh, like I just
always eat, gave me, and then I,
I wasn't even thinking about,
I had some clients show up and they
brought some steaks, like beef sticks.
So I just throw them on the grill.
Like I cook every,
I mean I cook all the time and
girls on fire, I'm like, Holy Shit,
what's going on?
And I realize I haven't cooked
a beef steak and probably ever,
I don't know. You know, it's a weird
thing to think. Like I just don't,
I've never cooked beef. You just
always eat game. Always a game. Yeah.
I wondered if it's a placebo
effect, you know, eating game,
like how good it makes
you feel afterwards.
But the reason why I don't think
it is is because of my kids.
I fed my three year old and my five
year old venison and they go at it like
they're fucking starving,
it's crazy.
And then they keep eating
it and like this is so good.
And they were really confused cause
they think deers are really cute.
They're like, this is deer. And I like
it's deer and they like, it's Yummy.
And I go, yeah tell me in. But I'm
watching them eat it and like it's,
they'd eat it way more voraciously.
Is that a word then? They do.
It doesn't sound like
it though. Can Be, it's,
it doesn't sound like it way
more aggressively than they meet.
Like if I give him steak, if I just
chop up beef steak, like they, I'll,
they'll eat it. But there's like a
like what is this? Well you know,
who else gets it?
Our are vegans and like raw food people
on the other end of the spectrum,
the very crunchy sort of hippie
because they'll say the same thing.
I eat this food,
it makes me feel alive.
I can feel like it just
feels better somehow.
It's the same thing with wild meat
there, right? You know vegans are right.
I feel great when I eat a lot of
like really fresh leafy vegetables.
I drink Kale shakes all the time in
the morning and I feel fantastic.
I feel all the nutrients in my body that
the problem with vegans of course is
just this crazy self,
righteous moral,
high ground attitude about eating animals.
When I,
I get the idea of not wanting to do harm,
but if you look at like real
studies as far as like farming goes,
unless you're growing all
of your own vegetables,
it's very likely or
participating in mass death,
the death of rabbits and rodents and
the destruction of habitat in order to
plant these crops and
God forbid if you use in
fucking pesticides and what,
what damage you're doing to
the environment. Like it's
not that God damn sample.
No.
Humans create so many extra
nowadays on everything. I mean,
you take a a plant that was never supposed
to be here in planet and you've just
wiped out something that should have been
there. You know what I mean? We cannot,
you can't go back from that.
Yeah. We fucked up a lot of things
like that. Right? Yeah. It's, I dunno,
I, I get where vegans are coming from. I
get someone wanting to be a nice person,
but it's just what I've always said is,
you know,
these animals don't live forever.
They're not bulletproof and
they're made out of food. Yeah.
But you're still going to try and all
wild game by the next. Yes. By 2014.
I'm going pig hunting with Steve this
weekend. We're going to, um, uh, to,
to hunt wild boar. I'm trying, by
the end of 2014 to be all wild game.
Have you calculated how much you need?
Yeah, I've got to kill some big shit.
Yeah. That's where the outcomes into play,
like freezer in my house.
We've got to elk in it right now.
We'll run through that for next
season. Yeah. I want to, uh,
an elk for sure. And maybe
even a buffalo. The Buffalo,
the buffalo that you got
to get another freezer.
Yeah, that's a partridge family tour bus.
Yeah. We killed the buffalo in Mexico.
It was a young female was the just the
finest meat I've ever had by far in my
entire life. Wow. Fantastic. That
was wild. That episode in Mexico,
because you got to see how these cultures
learn how to preserve their meat.
In the absence of
refrigerators and electricity.
They came up with all these interesting
methods in order to make sure that the
meat didn't go bad and one of them was
they would take these very thin strips of
steak and then hang it over like a hanger
and it would all dry out and then they
would chop it up and reconstitute
it with water and then cook with it.
It was called the chocolate.
Yeah.
I had had my chocolate and
eggs before the Mexican joint,
but I didn't know what the fuck
it was and I just took, I go,
what's good and guys like Machaca
and eggs like, all right man,
like beef jerky and eggs. Yeah. Well
it's not though. It's like a pull pull.
Once I reach that instituted then
it's, yeah. Once they get it wet again.
Yeah. You just soak it. Yeah.
They add water to it. Yeah.
I don't, I don't understand.
Oh, okay. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah.
But it was a wild watching these different
people and these different cultures
try to preserve meat and
figure out how they, you know,
they would like try to figure
out how to keep it to stay alive.
Once you know you're going to have to
shoot another buffalo and a couple of days
when everything starts rotting.
Can you picture the little old lady on
there that cut that meat up and dried it?
Can you picture her face? My
grandpa has a crush on her. Really?
Your grants crush on her? He did that, uh,
have Alina of duty.
That was a great episode. You guys
ate a coyote. That was interesting.
It wasn't bad. It wasn't good. It
wasn't bad. That was weird though. What,
what had gotten indeed the both of
your heads, you and Steve Vanilla,
she would have fucked up when your,
when your guy like me or Steve like
you've been thinking about that since
you're four years old, you're like, dude,
I just want to eat a coyote one day.
You know, and then it's like you get
two of you together and you're like,
let's go eat some coyote and
see what it tastes like. Well,
I'm going to have to eat one
spin sneaking around my yard.
They're trying to figure out how
to get to my chickens. He Fox.
It's so we'll get there. Oh I know they
will fucking creeps. I was in my, uh,
I was in my yard.
I was just about to let the chickens
out and I see this mother fucker looking
through the fence just looking right at
me and they're looking at the chickens
like, Whoa, that's kind of creepy.
It's like you have imagined
having a friend and you know
that the friend is safe,
but right outside the door you could
see a guy wants to kill your friend and
he's just trying to figure out a way
to get in and then that's what it was.
He's going to get in and kill
your friend with his face.
And his chickens are like my little
friends, you know, they, they lay eggs.
I say hello girls. You know, I
feed them. They, they bucking,
they come near you when the,
you know,
when you come out in this country
fucking dog, what's an eat Mike friends.
I had a, we had some chickens,
you know, we're deciding,
okay we're going to let him free cause
they gotta they gotta get out and they
got a pack and they got to get some
bugs and they're just happier. Yeah.
So we let the chickens out. Well I
didn't know their neighbor had a rooster.
The rooster comes over. Right.
And he just claims my chickens.
And so you'd go out to feed the chickens,
the rooster would come attack you.
I mean he would just get up there, spur
your legs, everything. Yeah. So I mean,
this is crazy rooster and we could not
keep him away from the chickens. I mean,
he's raping my ladies.
I want,
my goal was the unfertilized
chicken eggs. Yeah. Yeah.
So we're trying to think like we
can't kill this dude's rooster.
I mean that's just not right.
So I got this concrete rooster and
I put it out by the chicken coop.
That rooster comes over and just start
to fight in this concrete rooster.
He kicked his own ass and
just left and never came back.
So if you have rooster problems,
man, just, just get a statue.
I kick his own ass.
That's amazing.
What a dumb fucking animal.
He was like scared to come back.
Stupid. I was telling this story on
the podcast. I don't know what it was,
but I was a,
I was going outside to close the coop
at night cause I'd forgot to close it.
We have, um, our, our lawn,
it's like this large grassy area and
there's an area where the chicken coop is
and they, they uh, you know,
they just wander around in the
grass and eat bugs and shit,
but right outside that is a fence and
there's like this woods and shit. And uh,
I was stepping up to the fence and
these d or just start as a middle of the
night, like two o'clock in the morning,
just fucking hauling ass bro Bro. Bro.
Fucking not because of me because
something was chasing them.
I just happened to be close enough where
it happened and I don't know what it
was, but I just stood there in silence
and I'm hearing wild kingdom shit.
No hundred pound deer at least running
away from whatever the fuck it was.
Maybe coyotes, you know, maybe
a mountain line. I don't know.
I thought I saw a coyote like a silhouette
over the in the distance, but it was,
you know, like I said, it was pretty
dark out so it's hard to tell,
but no more than a couple,
150 feet at most from me.
Cause like this crazy shit taking
place like right in my yard.
I live in Suburbia, you know,
I don't, I don't live in,
never seen a line or lines side.
Seemed to, not in my neighborhood,
but I've seen two ever.
I saw one in Colorado that
actually want to eat and my dog,
I had a little dog get killed in Colorado
mountain line. It's a little one.
It was my wife's dog. It was say a
Pomeranian American Eskimo mix. Cute dog.
Too Sad.
But I have a giant dog and the giant
dog would pal around with the two little
dogs and everything was cool.
But the giant dog hurt his arm.
So he was inside his Paul and he was
inside and the two little dogs are out by
themselves and the mountain
lion was like, okay, this is,
I've been waiting for this.
Here we go.
This year I'm in my hunting lodge might,
my girlfriend was doing some cooking,
the cooking and stuff and so she leaves
our little cabin to go to the lodge,
start breakfast and like dark,
you know, she comes, she's like,
I saw mount mine freaked out.
You know,
it was like right here
by the port and I'm like,
wasn't a mountain lion as a deer, you
know, it's like just run over there.
It'll be fine. Okay. So she runs
over there and then all of a sudden,
like a week later these, uh,
we, we left some capes out.
Disappearing capes. Yeah. Like elk,
Kate, you know, like, oh the boss,
we skinned, we skin an elk
out, had the head and the
high detached to it, you know,
it just sitting there underneath where
we had all the meat hanging and this is
just like right behind my cabin disappears
and I'm thinking somebody messing
with us, you know, so
we're me and my brother,
I'll blaming everyone who's
hiding these things next day.
It happens again after everybody left this
time. What the Hell is going on? Well,
it snowed that night.
Sure enough, came back.
There's been a cat living just like
right behind the cabin in mountain lion
stealing shit. And I was like, oh, okay.
I guess it was kind of, it must've,
it was like right there by the porch
hanging out at night. You know,
I think that was what was going on
with my dogs too because this thing,
what whatever was there had been circling
around the house for a couple of days.
The dogs would go fucking crazy at night,
not just normal crazy but fucking
crazy. Like, and I'd be like,
what are you fuckers barking that come
on inside and that bring them inside and
they'd be like real jumpy and looking
around. So it had been around a while.
It was about 70 pounds, something
like that wasn't a big one, you know?
And then another one
I saw in Santa Monica,
or not a Santa Monica Santa Barbara
just driving down the street at night.
So this thing run across the street and
I thought it was a coyote and then I see
its tail, it's got this floppy cat tail.
I was like, Oh shit, that's a mount mine.
I still don't have a confirmed sighting.
And it pisses me off. It really,
it's like the one thing I
haven't really experienced.
I put this up on my Twitter,
somebody sent me,
this is one a Jack and Jack
dear underneath the feet
or somewhere in Georgia.
West Virginia. Yeah. The Guy said it was
West Virginia, but apparently it's not.
Apparently was Georgia,
that original photo.
A lot of people claim their
friends sent that picture,
but it's a big fucking animal man.
Forearms on those fuckers.
Quite a few out in the wild.
A couple of years ago actually
I was fishing in the spring
and found one cotton, a log jam
after flood dead one, you know?
Yeah.
It was the first.
I've never seen deadline anywhere
and that was the first one.
It's like an inner river.
Steve found a crazy photo that his friends
sent him of an elk that got killed by
a tree. The tree fell and the
elk was literally open mouth,
like this mama side, right. Frozen, solid,
frozen solid and see if he could find
that. It's on. Steve Rinella is a Twitter.
Um, but just, it's still freaky. It's
image. It's just like, it's screaming,
like as the log landed on it and
killed it, you know, it's just,
it's mouth stayed open as
it died. It was crazy. Yeah.
I guess if you're out there in long
enough, you see enough crazy shit. Yeah.
That's the thing. When
you're out there all, I mean,
you just never know what you're
going to see from day to day. Okay.
Here's the question. Big Foot,
big foot. Is He loud? Yes or no?
I want it to be, you know, I just
can't buy it man. I just don't buy it.
It's uh, I think, uh,
my grandpa used to like get a little
bit liquor shop and he would put on a
gorilla suit. He would run
in boxers. Yeah. He was like,
he's like one of the most crazy person's
is ever walked the face of the earth,
I think. But he would run in
front of logging trucks, you know,
and then they would freak out on
the radios and stuff. And then, uh,
he would go into the bar and I mean,
these dudes would be ghost
white and talking about how
they saw big foot and you
know, in their mind they saw big foot,
you know, and he loved it. You think like,
you see these tracks,
he's the guy that would put big foot feed
on and walk around with his buddy for
no reason. Like they just love to
do that. It's like there's big foot,
but there's dudes that like to make
people think there's big foot more than I
think there's actually a big foot's.
Yeah, I'm with you. Um, I, uh,
I think there's a lot of people that
like to fuck with people and that's
probably a lot of what people
are seeing it up there.
I got approached that this one show by
this dude that was a professional squash,
squash hunt,
right.
And he has a business card and everything
works out of Colorado and he's like,
man, I'll, I'll take you. And he's
like, for, for three grand or whatever,
I'll take you out.
And he's,
he's telling me about the
family groups of the squashes,
squashes whatever you gone. And,
uh, how he knows him and he,
and they're really elusive, but he sees
him all the time. And, uh, you know,
he does these guided tours and I'm
thinking to myself, who's crazier?
That dude or the people that go with him,
you know.
And then the other thing is what's,
I don't know if it's crazy or if he
believes himself or if he just straight up
lying to you, you know, like,
does he believe his own bs?
They're all a little delusional.
We, uh, for the Scifi show,
we went to Mount Rainier in
Washington state and we met
a lot of people, uh, that,
uh, had claimed to seen bigfoot.
And some of them were interesting.
There was this one woman
who is really interesting.
She seemed like she was telling the truth.
She saw a bunch of elk run away and
then she saw this thing, she's like,
it was a gorilla. She's like,
I'm looking at a gorilla.
What the fuck? And she was, didn't have
a website. She wasn't selling a book.
She didn't send, it seemed like she was
lying. I don't know what she really saw.
She might've seen a brown bear or a
black bear that was like in the woods,
in between, you know, trees. She might
have saw it moving in a weird way.
Convince herself that it was a gorilla.
Yeah.
Here's the thing,
I took a criminal justice class and in
the class everybody's sitting in there
with 400 people in this room and the
teacher had somebody come in and steal a
laptop from someone you know in the class.
Like didn't tell anyone.
And as everybody write down in
the description, if somebody,
the guy that came in and nobody's
matched up, you know what I mean?
Like your mind tells you what you want to
think. You know, you fill in the blanks,
especially if adrenaline's going
or it's new to you. I mean,
now if it was a guy that say,
I would say is in the woods all the time,
like an expert at animals.
I mean most people in the wild at
deer runs away in a split second.
They don't know if it's a white tail
or a mule deer. Right. You know,
I'm in like how do these people have
the expertise to identify a species when
they, uh, you know, or half a mile
away, they don't have proper equipment.
And they were going, oh
yeah, I saw a big foot.
And you're seeing it for a
half a half a second. Yeah.
Two second period of time. Two
seconds is one, two, boom. It's gone.
And then your memory has to feel it
when all this, what was it? And
then you tell yourself what it was.
If we spend enough time in the woods,
I will get one on camera. Yeah.
If they exist,
if it exists.
How much time do you guys ever
spend in the Pacific northwest,
which seems to be like the hotbed
for sidings. Just southeast Alaska.
We spend a lot of time there, but not
much in Washington if they're anywhere,
they're in Canada.
The only one that
I believe is Les Stroud.
Survivor man. Yeah.
He told me he had an
encounter Ridell market.
Well,
he said he was in his tent hand
and he said he had heard something earlier
in the day that was weird. He here,
he'd heard some something
walking through the woods, uh,
but he didn't see anything.
And then he said he was in his tent
at night and uh, it was, uh, you know,
pitch black in Alaska and in the middle
of nowhere flew two hours by plane to
get there to land on this lake.
And then they get out and be in his
tent and he heard some stomping.
Like you heard something that was clearly,
it seemed like by pedal that was walking
around and he said it was like total
silence and he heard this thing
and then he heard it, you know,
I think he said like less than a
hundred feet away from him cola
make this crazy noise,
like a primate noise that he thought
and he goes and reaches for his camera.
It hears his movement and just
runs away. Hmm. Interesting. Yeah,
it's very interesting.
The reason to me that it's interesting
is because that fucking guy goes
everywhere.
He'll go to the middle of nowhere and
survive and he's not a bullshit artist.
He seems legit. If it ended up being that
he wasn't legit, that'd be pretty sad.
I would be like, then doubt, my
ability to take on it was like, look,
if you're, you want another beer, whatever
you want, man, I just, water's good. Um,
here's his take on it.
Was that like,
how often do you see a wolverine if you're
just hiking, how often do you see, uh,
you know,
there's a lot of animals that exists
out there and these aren't even smart
animals. If this thing was living
in the Pacific northwest, he's like,
it's so dense up there and there's so
much area where people just don't get to
that. Something could possibly
live in small numbers there.
That's his tail a lot.
But the problem is everybody I talked
to that believes they've seen it almost
everybody. It's just the cookie. They're
fucking, they're nutty people, man.
They just,
this is not a,
like a doctor who was just on vacation
and saw something and had this definitive
sighting and the lack of
trail camera pictures,
zero trail camera pictures.
And there there's crazy enough dudes,
it will dedicate their whole lives to
finding it. You know, I mean, they exist.
We've got, we've got, but now did
you hear about the, um, they, this,
they were doing a bare studies in the
Sierras and one of the researchers got a
trail camera,
picture of a wolverine.
They didn't know what marines were still
in the Sierras. Wow. And it's like,
where's this wolverine come from?
You know, I've been in this,
I've spent a lot of my life and
this year has never seen wolverine,
never seen a track and never even thought
of singing overing and here they've
got, you know, you know,
legitimate biologists found it.
Well, how about that mountain
line they found in Connecticut?
I didn't hear about that. Not every
wine freelancer everywhere now. Well,
it came from South Dakota and walked from
South Dakota to Connecticut. They when,
when it died, something to get hit by
a car or something. And in Connecticut,
whatever killed it. And Connecticut,
they, they, they did the lineage on this.
They apparently had noon knew where this
animal came from and we were able to
trace it all the way back to South Dakota.
So I walk a thousand fucking miles.
It's a trip. Yeah. That's pretty crazy.
It's kind of lying and Connecticut.
There's coyotes in the Bronx, like,
yeah, the big park up there. We'll,
Chicago has a fucking whole population
of them. They know that the story.
Chicago park has a whole population of
them. They have a whole population of a,
of coyotes that are apparently a part
of the, the ecosystem they're eating.
What garbage? Eating rats.
No Shit. Well, that's good.
Let me make sure this is not Chicago,
not Detroit.
I'm sure
most big cities have coyote population.
I've seen a,
I've seen pictures of coyotes
just carrying like license
plates down the street.
I didn't, uh, yeah, it is. Uh, it is,
uh, there's, they have them tracked.
It's an ecological study of coyotes
and the Chicago metropolitan area area.
I didn't even see anyone until
I came to La and I was uh,
I was staying in Burbank when I first
moved here and I was driving down the
street and I see three Coyote's walking
down the street. And I was like,
this is something like apocalyptic
shit. These creepy, a little murderers.
Oh all look a little cute.
Coyote puppies.
Y'All in Chicago.
They're all good until they get hungry
and they start eating your kids.
Kid's your lap dogs. Yeah. And then
you realize, oh, these are creeps.
These are creepy little predators
that live amongst us. I knew a lady.
You've got a little dog snatched
right off. Release trolling
for trolling for coyotes. Yeah,
one of the coyote fishing.
What are the challenges that we're looking
to do for the new show is to harvest
some coyotes and then take the skins
and wrap ourselves in the skins and then
getting close, like sneaking on an animal
using k using camouflage of the Kyle.
It's like pretend to be accountable.
Let's talk about that new show.
Why don't you, uh, Jamie, let's play the
clip that I emailed you. Apex Predator.
Yeah. Apex Predator. This
is a new show that uh,
Dan's producing mommy's going to
be a part of. Let's check this out.
Now it's on the media.
Yeah,
there is,
but one law of the land
kill or be killed.
In life there is death,
but in death
there is life.
It took command thousands of years to
climb to the top of the food chain,
but we didn't do it alone.
Nature itself was our teacher
and those who hunted us,
he our guides.
And though in today's world
we have no natural predators,
there are still many timeless lessons
that nature can teach us to hold our
hunting skills and earn the right
to be called apex predators.
If you look at humans, what's pushed
us forward? They need to survive.
How do we survive by eating?
What do we eat other animals?
So what we're doing here is essentially
something I like to call hunt science,
the science of how things have
hunted and how things have evolved.
In order to do this,
we need to break it down into pieces,
dissected every bit of nature.
He didn't attempt to adapt and
replicate the strategies, skills,
and techniques are the most
proficient hunters in the world.
Concealment
Stealth,
tracking
in guarantees,
mental focus and heightened
sensory perception
by studying nature and analyzing the
traits of the fiercest hunters on earth.
All device,
unorthodox training techniques to push
beyond my limits in a modern technical
hunter and tap into the primal
instinct of Apex Predator.
It's the first morning
the sun isn't even up yet.
We've already got a herd of elk.
Every,
I've seen wolves catch, you know, they've,
they've started in a funnel like this
where one wolf will be on an opposite rig
and we'll kind of how back and forth
and then one will make their new.
By the time they get to the second one,
we've already started to wear her down.
We can keep them in this bowl.
We have the upper hand.
Yeah.
So when then wolf signing,
the first thing he's gonna do is sneak
into the herd and then get the hurting
moving once he gets the herd. Moving.
PACS and job is to cause confusion.
What this'll do is separate is prey and
his intended target from the rest of the
herd. Now he'll continue to push
me out to the point of exhaustion.
The Wolf's goal is to maintain his
energy levels while wearing the elk down.
Once the elk is on the new,
the wolf skin to try to cut him off,
we can see out on the region.
Let's just keep hitting them back
and forth with King first day,
let's just kind of
disoriented after he's cut the herd of
elk off and then he's gonna move in for
the kill.
That looks bad
coming fall 2014 where are you
guys going to have this song?
What's it going to be on? That's
a secret. That's a secret.
It's just he's still in negotiation.
Yeah, still trying to figure that out.
It looks dope though. It looks,
it's very excited. Thank you.
I get excited about it. It seems
like sneaking up on an elk with a,
with a bow might be one of the
most fucking thrilling things ever.
So on that episode, what our goal
was was it wasn't sneak up on them.
We actually pushed them and then
random down, exhausted, exhausted.
Yeah. Wow. Like it's almost sort
of a persistent Sinai as a person.
It's not anything we're, well, what
we did was we tried to do it like,
like a pack of wolves would.
So we,
we went in here with the idea that the
only way we're going to kill one is if we
do it like a wolf would.
Now we have to have a bow because that's
like the law and everything. I mean,
Ruby like hell, it's try spears, but
it's not legal, you know? Um, so we,
so we got the herd, we snuck in like
the wolves would, then we pushed him.
And then what we did was the,
the elk kind of have these escape routes.
And because I mean,
I've spent accumulation of just,
if you just counted the straight days,
it'd be like something like six
years chasing these elk, you know,
and just like straight 365 days a year,
six years worth of if you
added up all the time. And, uh,
so I mean,
I really know this herd and how they
move and elk in general, you know,
I've studied elk for a long time and uh,
so what we did was while elk would go up
and down every ridge, we would run up and
catch them up, know, like cut them off.
So they would like,
we'd be racing to the same place,
but they would be going a harder
route, you know, so they would be like,
their tongues are hanging out,
they're tired.
And what we're trying to do is get in
front of them hoping that by the time we
catch up and run them long enough that
they are tired and are just like walking
past us and we can kill them.
You have to be in fucking crazy shaped
to get elk tired. It was ambitious.
Fucking elk run a fat. They're huge. They
do the thing that we have going for us,
those, I mean, uh, like humans can sweat.
Yes. Animals can't make pant. You know,
they've got, they've got their
tongues out, they're tired fast.
There are big animal, you know,
we are really light. We're mobile.
We can carry water, we can refuel.
If an elk wants to refuel, you know,
how much grass he has to eat because
they don't break us. I mean grasses,
the hardest thing to digest on the planet,
you know,
and they need special enzymes to do it.
We can just power down a shot blocks
or whatever and just keep running.
It's really fascinating to actually look
at the science behind it and find out
what a human is capable of compared
to a four, a four legged animal.
Because in endurance situations
we have a pretty good situation.
Like it's something that humans can do.
And what things, the big part of it,
it's a big part of it.
But also,
I mean a little bit of like
kind of how like wolves hunt is,
is a lot of intelligence. You
know, they outsmart their prey. Um,
and a lot of it's the pack mentality.
Hunting is a pack. Pushing them.
Like we kind of created this pack and
in that episode we created a pack where,
you know, myself and my brother were
hunters. And then we also have, you know,
we aren't, we're filming this
so we have guys with cameras.
So we incorporate them in the pack
as part of the strategy and uh,
gets a little while to get
to western. You know, I mean,
you're trying to film yourself and
for other dudes are three other dudes,
chase elk through the mountains and to
the point where you can kill one like a
wolf would. Well, it's cool that you're
taking a novel approach to, to uh,
another outdoors slash hunting type show.
You know,
this is a very novel approach.
I like the science part of it the best.
It's just like we're doing these little
experiments like learning about what an
animal actually has in it's biology and
then like seeing if we could match it
and learning about it. And the process
to me is just fucking fascinating.
And in each episode two,
there's a huge training element.
It's not like we're trying to bullshit
people, you know, it was like,
if I'm going to do this, man, I've got
to learn something and try to adapt it.
And so, you know, we went out there and,
and that's where that vo two Max test
they were talking about earlier as part of
this episode where it's like, okay,
how do we stack up against wolves?
And it's like, dude, you're aren't
gonna Stack. I mean we, we ended up,
we got like this 90% Wolfen race that Jay
and it wasn't like I'm going to beat a
wolf. Oh No. He's just like, it was like,
let's see how bad I get my ass kicked in
the mountains so you know where I stand.
Like is this even going to be possible?
Because if you tell like a normal
hundred like, yeah, we're going to run
an elk down and kill it, run it down yet,
bullshit. You know, right now,
how are we going to go about this and
is it even possible after we raised the
dog, we're like, this isn't going to work.
And we went and did the vo two
Max test and everyone's like,
well if anyone on this plan, it's going
to do it. It's probably going to be you.
You know, you learn that. Uh,
so Remy had an extraordinarily
high vo two Max Score,
but it wasn't a third of what a train
canine is like a dog that's in shape is
something in the range of 300,
which is just sending us,
did you ever see the Werner Herzog film
happy people? Yeah. Life that taiga.
Do you remember when the guy comes back
to camp on his snowmobile and the dog
falls in the entire way?
Doug runs the whole distance and sell
like a full day of writing this fucking
the snowmobile. The dog is just full clip
trotting next to him for the whole day.
I think those,
like I did a rod canines are some of the,
they're the most fit animal on
the planet. God, that's crazy.
Imagine they don't have sweat either.
It doesn't matter.
They're just designed for that. Yup.
And, and they got that pack thing going.
I mean, they're all running together,
you know, he's just like, you know,
when you go do something with like
your friends that are pretty hardcore,
you ended up doing more than you wanted
to. You know? It's like, it's like any,
anytime I tried to go do something,
I'll go with guys that are better than me,
you know, because it's just going
to push you further than you think.
So those dogs getting his pack and
they just start pushing each other,
pushing each other, pushing
each other, you know?
And that happened to us while we
were out there. It's like, you know,
here's Dan and,
and uh,
dawn was another guy that was running
the camera and here were all out there
just like kicking our own asses and
everybody's doing it and it was awesome.
You can't, you can't really underestimate
the power of influence, the power,
the influence of a other bad
motherfuckers that are around you.
That's why I've always tell people,
if you want to have a good life,
surround yourself with a bunch
of bad motherfuckers. Exactly.
They're doing a bunch of bad ass shit.
You're going to want to do bad
ass shit and you're going to,
and we're going to want to keep up with
them when you're going to be around them.
Your standards would be higher
if you're the most bad ass guy,
you know you aren't going anywhere.
That's one of the reasons why it's
really dangerous in camps like it.
Mixed martial arts camps that comes into
play with you are the Alpha dog of the
camp because people sort of Beta you and
you know you kick everybody's ass and
then you go in there with another alpha.
You're not used to dealing with that.
You don't,
you're not used to like rising to the
occasion when you're confronted with an
equal adversary and it comes down to,
you know,
focus and discipline and willpower. Yeah,
it's good to be king, but I guess not.
No,
no good.
It's good to be one bad motherfucker in
a troop of other bad motherfuckers all,
you know, become a brotherhood and
push each other. That's, that's a,
that's an interesting thing. Everybody
wants that. The alleviation of pressure.
They want to be the top dog,
but there's,
that's a trap trap because
if you become that,
then you don't grow and then you're done.
You know it's his time to die.
There is no, there's no peace. No one
gets peace. There will be no rest.
You never get to retire. You
know? Like someone said to me,
what are you gonna do when you attire?
I go die. That'd be when I'm dead.
I'm not retiring from Shit
and was the songs of live.
I'm going to keep doing what
I enjoy doing. You know?
And maybe some of it won't make any money,
but I treated the same way as the
shit that I do that does make money.
There's no retiring. Shut up, bitch.
There's no, there's no golden rainbow.
There's no, no, there's no fucking boat.
You're going to get off and you're
going to die. You're going to live,
you're gonna die while you're alive. Stay
alive. Stay alive and keep moving. Yeah.
This idea that we just go out to
pasture for third of our life is like,
okay, those are your golden
years. I don't know about that. I,
I'm going to go hard just
as long as I can. You know,
I'm riding this pitch
right into the rocks.
Keep the throttle going
and when it hits the beach,
just hope your momentum carries
you right into the rocks. Boom.
Otherwise, fuck it, man. Those
last few years are terrible.
They're all on antidepressants,
sir.
Drill it into your fucking lemonade.
Get outta here man. What can we come on?
What are you trying to do? My buddy
always said he'd start doing heroin.
Returned 83 that's good. That's good
here. Yeah. If I had like terminal cancer,
boom. Heroin's a first shit. I try. I
want to know what the fuss is all about.
You know,
I'm getting a fast car and see if I
can drive across the country backwards.
Your gears are blow up. How long do you
think are good car can go in reverse.
Even go a mile. Oh yeah,
yeah. Maybe ship. No,
they're not.
This one gear though.
Like if you had to drive in
first gear across the country,
how long would that last? You know,
fucking your transmission would explode.
It'd be like, what are you doing
stupid fucking rebs in this thing.
Something we give out, I dunno,
whatever that means. Nothing. Um,
being in, uh, this, uh,
this world where you hunt,
you know,
200 plus 300 plus days a year,
what's the reaction when you talk to
like a normal person who doesn't have
anything to do with hunting and they
find out you do so much of this hunting,
what does, what does the standard
reaction? Is there a typical reaction?
Yeah, actually. I mean,
I think most people are like
receptive of it and they're like,
that's bad ass because it will
for a lot of reasons. One,
it's like very few people do what they
love every single day. Like I tell people,
I've never worked a day in my life, you
know, I mean, I love it so much. If,
if I had to choose what I was going to do,
it'd be what I'm doing and I don't
care who you are, what you like. Like,
people respect that, you know, if somebody
tells me something that they're into,
you know, maybe like ballet,
it's like not my thing.
But if that's your thing and you're
doing it and you love it, that's cool.
Like that's, that crosses any barrier
of what, you know, what you don't know,
you know? Um, because I think a
lot of people aspire for that.
And then the other part is, I mean,
a lot of people now more than ever,
I think this idea of
hunting and kind of living,
maybe not necessarily living off the land,
but just being there eating wild
meats and other things. It's like,
it's a trend that's popular now and people
are interested in it. I think I've, uh,
like people find out, they're
like, really? You do that?
Ah, man, what do you eat it?
Yeah. You know, like, I'd like
to try that or you know, I mean,
just also people ask, you know, a lot of
crazy questions like, what? Uh, you know,
like, what's the craziest
thing you've ever seen?
What's the craziest thing you've
ever done? Because it's a wildlife,
it's a essentially,
I mean,
I compare my life to probably
that of pioneers a long time ago,
that those were the guys that wrote
the stories that people read. You know,
they wanted to hear about real
adventure. And it's like, I mean,
I tell people out there, I mean it's,
when you're out there, it's legit. I mean,
I've been in a lot of
life or death situations.
I've seen a lot of things
that people will never seen.
I've been places where I bet
very few humans have ever been.
What is the most extreme life or death
situation you think you've ever been in?
One that stands out and so
mad and um, yeah, I mean,
from a very early age,
I've run into a few that I was struck
by lightning when I was a kid. Yeah,
that was, that was interesting. Um,
maybe that's your deal, man. That's it.
Dude.
You got struck by lightening. Fuck.
How old were you? I was, I was like,
it was before kindergarten is just like,
it's like my first memory, you know,
just a little kid were, and this wasn't
even, I wasn't even out anywhere.
It's just backyard with my
dad looking over the city.
We just got done putting up a
basketball hoop. Boom Fried.
Whoa. So it was the basketball hoop
itself that attracted the electricity,
but it was like, yeah, it was over
a mile away was the clowns and a,
they call it like bolts over the blue.
It just,
those lightning bolts can go up to a
mile away from there, their center.
And it was one of those massive,
like in Nevada lightening is,
it just happened because there's so
many independent mountain ranges.
As clouds move creates positive, negative
energy and then they're super powerful.
I mean, it was, uh, you know, it was a
crazy experience, but I was, you know,
I was pretty young. Um, I remember it.
My Dad might mean my dad both got struck.
My Dad was paralyzed for almost a month,
just like nerves grew back.
You know, Holy Shit, your dad
was paralyzed for about, yeah.
Maybe, maybe a few weeks, three
weeks, something like that.
And then just like neck down. I know
from the waist down. Yeah. Oh my,
he got hit above the waist and the
doctor said that he wouldn't be alive,
but he was, he was, he was like, he's,
you know, an athlete too. I mean,
I think a lot of the vo two
Max comes from my jeans.
I've got like on both sides of the family,
just super athletes and uh,
my dad run every day and his heart
can handle that burst. I was, uh,
I got struck below. I got struck in
my right leg right above the knee,
came out right below the knee lift
like a pencil sized bruise all the way
through my leg. And uh, you know,
I mean I, I woke up, I didn't
really know what was going on.
It's Kinda like people ask,
I remember it pretty well.
And when the movie saving
private Ryan came out,
when that bomb goes off right next
to the guy, you know, and it's like,
everything's like quiet but weird.
It was exactly like that.
I think like anybody that's kind of
had some kind of shell shock like that,
that clip and that movie is so realistic.
Like the dude that made that clip had
to have experienced that, you know,
it's so loud, you can't hear anything.
You're like, everything's confusing.
I mean,
you're like watching the rain phone,
slow motion because your heart's going
so fast. All he feels your heart,
you're like watching rain, like,
like lands on your skin, explodes,
lands on your skin to expose.
People are talking to you,
but it's like they talked to
you three seconds ago, you know,
like a three second delay kind
of thing and you're like, ah,
I don't know what's going
on. Then blackout again. Wow.
And so what was the physical repercussions
for you? For me, I've, you know, I,
I remained pretty unscathed.
I had a twitch for until
I was about 17 you know?
So what does it look like?
What did that switch thing pretty
much gave just broken record.
Yeah, it's wild years of my
life. I would twitch man.
And it was like I was the kid at school
that had the twitch, but it'd be like,
that kid got hit by lightning, you know,
he's like, that's why he's got the twitch.
So what would you do? Like give me an
example of the two. I was like, um,
I don't know. Not that bad, but
like I can't, I can't even do it.
Maybe if I do it on my insight,
some muscle memory,
it's like never there now does it?
Um, not really. I mean, you know,
like you feel it a little bit and you're
like, no, no mental control and no.
So you feel it coming on and you could
give in. It's like a CS. Yeah. I mean,
I haven't felt it for a long time.
Like I think I've been over the hump long
enough where it just doesn't come back.
That's an incredible 12 years of
twitching. That's, uh, yeah, that,
that was a pretty harrowing
experience as a child. But, um,
in my recent years I had a,
a pretty crazy experience.
Uh, it's almost like kind
of hard to talk about.
It's just one of those
like weird deals. But, um,
I was, uh, I was in
Montana. I've got like a,
I'm an outfitter and that's how I make my
living is taking people on expeditions,
hunting or whatever, all over the world.
And A, I've got a lodge based in Montana.
And so we're building this,
um,
this outdoor shower bathroom thing.
Cause we do this big 4th of
July party every year, right?
And so my place is right on the river
and it's springtime and it's one of the
highest runoffs we've ever had.
Um,
so the water is a all spring runoff and
they measure rivers in cubic feet per
second.
So the river normally would say
is like 300 cfs this weekend.
It was flowing, it 3000 cfs. So
that's like the same size river,
but that much water.
I mean,
he's just ripping and it's that kind of
water where you put your hand in it and
it's ice cold. Like, I mean
a lot like that glacial river
that, that Steve crossed.
And,
uh,
so I'm out there building the thing
and my family's helping me. And, uh,
had been Raf's going by kind of a little
bit throughout the day cause it's a
really nice day is father's day. And I
hear somebody yell, I was thinking, okay.
So I walked to the edge of the river
and I see all the ship floating down.
I'm thinking this is not good. You know,
somebody must've turned their boat.
And uh,
here comes his lady floating face up
and she just locks eyes with me and she
says, help me, help me.
I'm going to go shit my,
by this time my mom had run up to the
river too and I take my cell phone and my
wallet on my pocket. I throw it to my
mom and I yell to her, call nine one one,
you know, and the lady, I yell
twice, I kicked the shore, you know,
and I'm to, and she's just like
looking at me, help me, help me.
And she's floating down the
river pretty quick. Well,
she hits a current and takes off, you
know, in the background. My mom screaming,
don't go in the river,
don't go in the river.
And she hits the current
and eyes just start running.
And to this day I do not remember,
like I,
I've walked through that area a lot of
times. I don't know how I ran so fast,
like I don't remember like in when it
was all over, I don't remember running.
I just remember being at the end of,
there's like this,
I mean trees and shit falling everywhere
and I don't know how I ran through it
so fast,
but I ended up hitting the highway and
running down the highway and there's this
corner where the river banks and there's
a big cliff on one side and then it
makes us giant rapid there.
Well I see her and she goes under the
rapid and at this point I hit the highway
and this truck had pulled off
and I, um, I yelled to the guy,
I say, uh, she pops up and she's
coming close to the shore now.
And I yelled to this guy who's
standing there. I say, grabber,
cause you just popped up. Well,
he reaches out and he was like,
I don't know if he freaked out or what,
like he grabs and you just misses her.
And at this point I'm like,
Oh shit. You know what I mean?
She was just alive and uh,
she's,
she's hitting the faster water
again and I just jumped in and uh,
so I jumped in and I,
I'm in the river with her and you know,
like my thought when I jumped in
was I'm not getting out of this.
It was like the weirdest,
weirdest deal ever.
So I jumped in and I grabbed her foot when
I grabbed her foot, she goes under, um,
so I kind of have to scoop her up under
the water and I start floating down the
river with her,
holding her up and I catch the rocks.
And, um, I just, luckily I was wearing my
hunting boots that day. They were like,
you know, tall hunting
boots, like nine inch boots.
And I think that's the only reason I
got out of the river because it made my
ankle is stiff enough. I could
catch the rocks on the bottom and a,
and then I drug her up on shore and
I, I tried not to move or, you know,
cause I didn't know if she
had a broken neck or what. Um,
so I get her up to the shore
and I, um, I check, you know,
first responder, you know, so I
do all this stuff and uh, I um,
check and make sure she's breathing
or whatever. There's like,
not really any signs of life,
but her eyes are open and she's got
a little bit of breath, tiny pulse.
So I just kind of like look at it.
It's like you're looking at her,
but nobody's home now. I'm, so,
I just grabbed her by the face and y'all
look at me, look at me, look at me.
And about after 10 times of yelling
it, it's like all of a sudden, boom,
someone comes to, she takes a
breath and was like, okay. Um,
I tell the other guy, go grab some
blankets and stuff, wrap her up.
And she looks at me and she says,
where's Dave? Where's Dave? I'm like,
you know, I don't know who's Dave,
you know, I mean by this time,
a lot of times past, I turn around and
on the bottom of the rivers, this guy,
all his clothes are ripped off and he's
going down the river head first on the
opposite side of the river. I
go, shit is dead dead. You know,
he'd been five minutes behind or maybe,
and uh, so at this point it's like,
you know, I just like, I didn't
really, you know, I mean,
here's an able body person that
was completely screwed, you know,
like in the river, completely screwed.
You know, what's the mean that I like,
I have no special skillset that they
don't have to get myself out of this,
you know, just maybe a little bit of
luck. Um, you know, I went in for her,
but you know, I mean, I
obviously knew this guy was gone,
so I threw something like that floated
over top of them because everything kind
of floats at a constant rate and we ended
up pulling him out of the rear two and
a half miles down. Um, he
had died. And obviously, um,
which, you know, it's like, it's
a really horrible experience.
The lady called me back the
next, the next day, you know,
cause she just lost her husband. It was
father's Day. And, uh, yeah, I mean,
it's like, it's, you're like,
okay. And then, you know,
you're going through all
these weird emotions.
Like I just jumped into river and like,
didn't think I was coming out of it.
And like the emotional shit
that you go through, you know,
it's like really a weird deal. And
then a, so she called and said,
I just want to hear your story. And then
I wanted to tell you my story, you know,
because it's like a, you just like, I
feel this connection with this lady now,
you know? And, uh,
so she tells me her story and she said
they were floating down the river.
They hit this back.
Eti,
the raft got s there was a log that
fell across the river and Raf get sucked
under the, the log and spits them
both up, you know, out, you know,
everything's gone.
They're floating down the river.
They weren't wearing life vests. And, uh,
they're holding hands floating down
the river. He says, I love you,
and then just disappears,
manage, and that,
so she says,
she tells me,
and it must have been at some point
after I saw her when she went under the
water. She said that, um, it was the
most peaceful feeling she'd ever felt.
She said it was like everything was white.
She says she knows her husband didn't
suffer. She's like, it was like she,
and then she heard this voice like
way off in the distance and a,
and just like latched
onto it and then came to,
and so the doctors,
the doctors told her that even
five more seconds in the water,
she would have been dead.
Her body had completely given up
and they said that it was like,
it was like this weird response. I just
started yelling at her. I don't know why.
Like I just,
it was like,
it felt like the right thing to do
and they said like that, that voice,
like gave her something to latch onto and
like let her body know that it's okay.
Like, you know, it was really weird. Wow.
Oh Shit. Yeah. That's crazy.
Yeah, that is a, that's what your risk,
when you go rafting, right. It's the,
these people deciding they
were professionals too. I
mean, this, this guy is,
they were, this is what they did for a
living. They were professionals. Wow.
You're just like, so they weren't just
tourists? No, they weren't tourists.
They were, they were scouting it out
before they took clients there. Oh my God.
Yeah. Rivers a fuck you this. You
know what I mean? You just like,
it's kind of like any professional,
you get into a certain mindset
where you'd call, you get,
you get too comfortable and like I, I've
been guilty of it, you know? I mean,
we all have in some,
some respects, you know,
it's like you ever take a motorcycle down
the street without a helmet, you know,
or what you know, just, just think
you can get away with it. Yeah.
Did we let them in Montana life vest?
No,
but the water was fucking six inches
deep. We kept bottoming out. Yeah.
Did that water was not killing me.
If I fell in that water I was getting
to the shore. That wasn't that fast.
It wasn't that dangerous. It wasn't
that spooky. That didn't bother me.
But if we were encountering some rapids,
I would've definitely wanted one.
But that was the water was,
it would've sucked if we fell in.
But most of it was like waist height.
Yeah. You know, it would have been fine,
but if we were in some like
serious, I would have been
shitting my pants on. Yeah.
I don't really like water and
me don't really mix sometimes.
And that's why I was like crossing
the thing with Steve. It's like
no shit, this looks a little
hairy. Brought up bad memories.
I'm not comfortable in water either.
My scariest a wilderness thing.
It was in the ocean with sharks.
Like I've been charged by bears.
We've had that Moose.
I've had all kinds of shit happen.
You been charged by bears
will on the unmetered. Oh,
let the Caribou one with Tim
Ferriss. Is that one? Oh No,
we got charged this last fall. That's
fucking, no. Yeah, you'll hear it.
You'll hear about a Friday with Steve
for sure. But yeah, we got charged.
We got by a mom, Gris and
three cubs. That's right.
You guys told me about that in Wisconsin.
She tracked us down and charge,
tracked you down and
show she fucking Christ.
But last year I was in Mexico with my
brother's spear fishing and had two bull
sharks come after us. Very
briefly. We spirit some fish.
The fish were about five feet away
coming in. These two monsters.
Fucking sharks come out of the depths and
just like coming right at me and there
was no,
there was no reaction because a,
I'm not comfortable underwater be,
what the fuck are you going to do?
I was like 15 feet on.
I was like on a dive.
It was just kind of like
suspended and it was,
it was just the most
completely, everything's
stopped actually with the bears,
everything's stopped too,
but I felt like I still had some
sort of control and control,
but with the sharks, it's just like a
bunch of armed people on the ground.
When the bear rushed,
everyone would had rifles.
But you know what's interesting
is that didn't bring any piece.
It's just like this extra thing that
happens is sort of extra sensory thing.
I think where it's that blissful moment
of nothing and it's happened a few times
in the woods when like
shit really goes down.
The shark was a little different
because it wasn't enjoyable.
The bear was somehow enjoyable situation
way previous where a kid went into Anna
Filactic shock.
I used to lead trips for teens,
basically fucked up teens
in the wilderness and had
one time a kid went to Anna
Filactic shock and couldn't breathe.
I like threw him over my shoulder,
carried him through the desert
of ways jasmine with an Epi pen.
And I remember coming out of that
experience just kind of like you said,
the sort of uh,
you just go into this sort of weird
connection with what's happening.
But she also like how you couldn't
remember how you ran to that thing.
I can't remember what
happened for two minutes,
but I brought this kid back like revived
him and that feeling of nothing is
something I've sort of been chasing sense,
which is just like this pure
action without thought, dislike,
beautiful, slow motion,
almost nothingness.
And yet everything is happening so fucking
quickly. It's amazing. But the sharks,
that didn't happen,
that was just shitting my pants
thing because in such an
extreme situation you're,
you're almost forced to abandon all
your extra thinking and all your
contemplation, worry, this, that
and the other thing. And it becomes,
you're just a pure organism trying to
exist and stay existing and you're rotting
100% on an instinct and a bear
is looking at, yeah, it's a peak.
It's just reacting perfectly.
Peak experience, man.
Do you think people get addicted?
Did that you'd look into it?
Fuck yeah, I don't think so.
I think on a light level, like I'll put
myself around it maybe, but no I don't,
you know,
I don't need to jump off shit.
I don't need to climb
the highest mountains.
But like the animal stuff and getting
that close like that is something that I
really, really fucking day and I haven't
come common with Ramey and Steve.
It's just like that
experience to me is priceless.
I'll tell you one thing that was
a really unusual to me about um,
going into Montana and a hunting,
well when I, when I killed that deer,
it was, this is what the unexpected
aspect of it. It was almost psychedelic.
It's almost like you're
in this weird world,
it's not your world and there's a being
in there that exists there all the time
and then all of a sudden you're,
your day.
It's almost like an illusion
or a or hallucination.
It's very strange when you're in their
world and you pluck one of them out of
there and drag it away and it's like,
what did we just
piled the animal?
There's a huge connection in cultures
between hunters and psychedelics and like
the journeys you take on a,
on psychedelics.
I think there's a clear
connection between it. I,
I'm just agreeing with you that,
that the hunting experience,
that sort of intensity or that sort of
connection with the natural state is so
not what we're in every day here.
That you come away from it different.
Well,
that's one of the things I,
I'm endlessly thankful to you guys about
is that experience in Montana because
the, what you guys picked wasn't like
Wisconsin where when we were in Wisconsin,
there was a road,
there was only a mile away and there
was a house and it was like, you know,
it was a farm. It's, it's, it's, it's
sort of wild. Yeah. But not really.
It's a bunch of weird animals and hanging
around the farm that you can eat their
farm animals kind of,
but you got to shoot him,
you know? I thank you for that moment
where you finished off that deer.
Yeah. I think you brought to our show,
I think you brought to like the public,
the most sort of poignant moment of
what it means to take a life and to kill
something in the wild. Like they didn't
like your face when you kill that animal.
You look at it, you're frozen
and then you breathe out heavily.
That is yet you told the story we've
been trying to tell and have been telling
over and over perfectly.
Wow. Well, you know, it was just a
hundred percent the raw experience.
And uh,
what I was going to say is I thank you
guys for introducing me to such a wild
adventure. It was completely wa no
cell phones. There was no internet,
there was no humans. We, what did we
see? We were there for how many days?
Five days did we see five
people, maybe, maybe three,
three people on boats that were going
down the same river. It was their world.
And we just sort of found our
way into their world. And uh,
just it was very psychedelic.
Very, very much so.
It's a totally a trip to go
into the wilderness like that.
And I sold my career before I was in TV
is I took people into wilderness for the
first time. That's what I did.
And you frame it the same way.
Well tell his story though,
because it wasn't just that you
actually did it with troubled kids,
which I found really fascinating.
Yeah. I did that for about
five years out of college.
I both for private pay companies where
families were just unhappy with how their
teams were acting and then also for state
correctional facilities so that those
are the ones that had the most fun
and probably where the state ones,
so every 21 days I'd go down around to
Minnesota is different juvenile detention
centers,
pickup 10 kids from the hood and drive
mode to the Wilderness for 21 days and do
these big in this.
In the winter we would do cross
country ski treks in the summer.
We'd can do in the shoulder seasons,
we would hike and it was just the,
just the most bad ass way to spend
my time. I did that for a long time
and you had a good success and kind of
getting to these kids because of that,
a Yankee in the amount of their world
and putting him something completely
different. Yeah. Giving them this,
this alternative perspective of being
in the wild that just sorta like makes
them like, what is the life I'm
living is the life I'm living?
Just something I'm used to and this is
not the only option and just a lot of
weirdness out there.
Absolutely.
They always left with something valuable.
They always left with something that
they would look at and look at things in
their normal life differently.
Did it pull,
pull all the kids away from
their habits and shit? No,
but was it a worthwhile
thing? Fuck yeah. You know,
as an alternative to staying in,
in prison or in jail.
It's like the alternative sentence to my
21 day program was maybe six weeks in a
juvenile detention center.
Fuck that.
You know like come out in the
woods and learn how to do shit.
Be responsible for yourself, be treated
respectfully, learn about nature.
Get some fresh air, like getting
shaped. Like that's, that's good.
No matter 21 days to like even if
you're in a crew or whatever, man,
if you don't have the modern conveniences,
the importance of self reliance is like
you can teach yourself so you're your
best teacher man.
You know?
I mean the idea of giving these kids
some kind of self reliance where they are
in charge of themselves in this situation
and they have to use their brains and
their whatever and pay attention and like,
I don't see how that could be beneficial.
Yeah. How it could not be. Yeah. I,
I've found it just beneficial
just to be away from people,
just to be away from the city,
just to be away from cars.
There's to be away from planes flying
overhead. It's not natural. That's not,
our bodies are accustomed to after
hundreds of thousands of years. Yeah.
It's weird. The air's different.
Everything's different.
You feel different when
you're not inundated with
radio signals and TV signals
and Wifi. It sounds like horse
shit. But if field that the fucking,
the quiet feels different out there.
It's a different quiet.
It's are displaying to people
that haven't experienced it too.
You know what I mean?
It's one of those things like if
you don't know when you got to,
you can't really explain it.
You can say it,
but you know you don't really
get it until you've done it,
which is why it feels like psychedelics.
It's kind of the same type of thing.
Once you've, once you've done
it, then you can talk about it,
but if you're talking to somebody who
hasn't done it, then it's sort of a,
it's just a different way of
experiencing things and you can share it,
which is what's really cool.
It's fun to share with you and Brian and
fun to share with all the people I've
taken out in the woods is that
that forms a bond, you know,
the very quickly,
in a very strong way.
I mean our wolf pack on the apex show,
just the hunting shows, you know,
it's different.
Something about that affects
your relationships with
the people you're out there
with.
It's good for 100% I think anytime you've
gone through something with someone
that's like really intense, it's
just your bond, your connection,
your understanding of each other.
And the world that you live in is very,
very unique.
Yeah.
There's something specific about dudes
I think that need that or crave that.
I worked with young
men mostly pretty much,
probably 95% and I think that's a huge
thing lacking in our culture is just that,
just that experience and then it's,
it's, it's, I think it's what we need.
We need to do that well. It's
certainly a part of it, of
who we used to be and I think tapping
into that a lot of times can give people a
sense of satisfaction that this doesn't
exist in the modern manufactured world
that we live in of
cubicles and nine to fives,
alarm clocks and all the nonsense that
we've come to accept as being life.
But it's not in fact your
body or your DNA itself,
the epigenetics that shaped you as an
individual are all based on ancestors that
never went through anything even remotely
close to what we're going through.
And when you do the stuff that
they used to do, you feel great.
That was happy people.
That was what it was all about.
Werner Herzog's documentary.
It's about these guys there.
There's no mental illness.
No one's depressed.
They're having a great fucking time.
All they do is hunt and fish and trap.
That's it. That's their whole life.
And we think that they're fucked up.
But meanwhile they live as long as
us and they die just like we die.
But they're happy.
The fucking hole tires
and can we think they're losers? They
live with an ease that you can't. Yeah,
I spent a lot of time like in the jungle
in South American and other places with
indigenous people.
There is an ease with which they go
through their day with which they talk to
each other with which they eat their
food, which is just like, it's, you know,
I went there pretty young to South
American side. I was like, Holy Shit,
I want that. I want to be around that.
I want to see what the fuck that is.
I want to like, you know, spend
some time and just see what,
cause it's different man.
It's just like we have this like up tight.
Even the most relaxed of us here in
America have this sort of uptight thing.
I got it fucking,
yeah,
it seems like a lot of people are
just worried about uncertainty or,
and then they get in these patterns
because it's, it's certain,
you know what I mean? It's
like, uh, what's going to
happen with the stock market?
What's going to happen with my 401k?
So they'd be getting these,
like we're such a pattern of all species.
I mean, like I've, I've seen, you know,
I've been to a lot of countries, I spent
a lot of time just like in the bush,
just watching animals in certain animals
have patterns because it's comfortable.
It's like predictable,
you know what I mean?
And there's no more pattern we'll
species than humans. I mean, we just,
we are like clockwork. You don't have,
because we don't like that uncertainty.
And then,
you know,
you throw yourself in a situation
where every day it's uncertain.
It's whatever. It's different.
And it's just like, it's,
you get out of that, you're happy,
you feel good. You know, like I,
I've been doing the solo hunter show
and that a lot of that comes out of my
thing has always been just,
it started out as,
I didn't have anybody to go hunting with,
so I would just go out in the
woods by myself. You know,
I think my longest trip was almost a month
just in the wild along. And it's like,
there's like, where'd you go?
Nevada wilderness. Wow. Yeah.
I think like Nevada I think is the
most untouched place in the lower 48
[inaudible] circus circus. I was, um,
on the Vegas strip between the palms.
I ate some ass cops left
behind hunting for 30 days,
but um, you know, I mean it was like
just short of a month. And uh, you know,
I think in that it was like a lot
of uncertainty, a lot of, you know,
everything was unpredictable,
but you're 100% relying on yourself,
which is just like this great. You're
happy, you know? But I think the other,
the other thing about it too is a lot of
people don't like being alone and it's
just,
I don't know if it did,
you just don't like yourself or you just
aren't familiar with yourself. You know,
I think people are
running away from a lot of the
issues that they have in their life.
And one of the ways that people run away
just by keeping themselves busy or keep
themselves distracted.
Yeah.
So I think some people just don't like
being alone because then they're like,
okay well here I am and oh maybe we
should just fucking think about who we are
here while we're sitting here.
It doesn't take long.
And you have like me turns out I
think I'm kind of a fucking idiot.
It's also the forest reevaluation of the
momentum that your life has taken on,
which is also uncomfortable because
it doesn't seem like he can stop it.
And it's also,
you know,
it's so much of who you are and it's why
so many people that live like terrible
lives defending, embrace that life. Cause
they don't want to admit they fucked up.
They don't want to admit that they've
probably been living their life on the
momentum of this like really shitty
decision that they made when they were 18
let's pick their college major or
whatever, whatever it was. You know?
And I like what you said
about the patterns too,
because that eliminating a lot of the
fear and uncertainty is a lot of what
people do. And it's a lot of why
people get good jobs. They all,
I'm just going to get a good
job that pays good. He's got it.
I got dental and you know,
and then who,
I don't have to worry about that
anymore and, but in doing that,
you kill all the fucking wild,
crazy fun of life.
You don't have those experiences, man.
You eliminate experience from life.
I wouldn't recommend you jumping
in the river and saving people,
but I think you jumped in the river and
saving that woman probably elevated you
as a human
fuck. Yeah. I mean it changed it
that day changed my life, you know?
I couldn't imagine it not, you just look
at everything different. You're like,
okay, it that given point. I
mean, it was almost like if I did,
it was a weird feeling, man.
It's like thing like, um,
I guess I don't care if I live or
die almost. But you do, you know,
it's like it's a weird feeling and then
so you live here the rest of the day.
He's like, man, cause I think I
made it out of that river. You know,
I'm going to really do something cool
this year. That's part of the addiction,
the addiction to that thing. So in that
moment when the bear is charging you,
it's that uncertainty, the idea of
uncertainty, but it's so fucking narrow.
It's like compressed into
this perfect moment. Like you,
you are going to die or you're not going
to die and you're not certain of it,
but it's so fucking acute. The
apps get that I think. Yeah,
I can imagine. You know, I mean if
somebody's shooting at you, he's like,
I'm going to work every day,
but are they really just going
to work or you know what I mean?
That kind of job where you're in the
line of of uncertainty and danger.
Yeah. I had a friend who was a cop when
I lived in Boston and he was in, um,
a fairly safe area, but he was
getting transferred and, uh,
he asked to get transferred to
a bad neighborhood. And I go,
why are you doing that? And he goes, more
action and I go, more action. He goes,
yeah. He goes, I'm a, you
know, I'm bored. I go, see,
you want to go with a crime as he goes,
that's why I'm a cop. I'm like, well,
you're, you should be a cop.
That he got the right mindset.
But he would talk very similarly about it,
about that he appreciates it,
appreciates the good aspects of his
life because of the bad aspects of the
things that he sees every day.
Yeah.
Cause the thrill and the danger
of, you know, not, you know,
you fucking kicked down a door and
you know, you're locked and loaded.
Who knows what the fuck is gonna
happen, you know, who knows?
Who knows what's going to happen when you
get out of that and you're okay. Whew.
That fucking,
yeah.
Lemonade taste sweeter. Yeah. It's
like you get this adrenaline rush man.
You know what I mean?
I've had a lot of other experiences.
Maybe not as extreme as that,
but you know,
a lot of other experiences in every time.
It's like that rush of adrenaline.
It's like, okay, well,
hey, I survived unscathed.
Like checking your body pretty unscathed.
Right on. Let's do this again guys.
You know. Well, we made it.
We're fine with one more time.
Maybe one more time around, but
what about wild animals? What's the,
the creepiest wild animal encounter
you've ever had? Uh, you know,
I had a bear,
um,
I was guiding this one guy in
New Mexico and I parked this,
I bought this brand new four wheeler and
parked it and we do this hike and for
sitting there like looking for
elk and I hear something by me,
I kind of like turn around
and look behind my shoulder.
Here's this bear standing off
force like right there. Okay.
So how far were 10 feet brown bear,
black, black bear, black bear,
black bears. Like, I'm not really afraid
of bears. It's not like something that I,
you know, I mean, I like it when I'm in
grizzly country. I like pay attention,
you know, but it's not like something
that keeps me awake at night. Um,
but you know, this bear kind of
comes around and like, okay, this is,
you know what I mean? His clothes,
he's like kind of inquisitive.
And the guy that's with me, he's like, you
have a bear tag, right? I was like, yeah,
he's like shooting. I was like, ah,
I'm not going to shoot this bear. Um,
but I was like, if it does something,
you know, shoot it, you know, it's like,
take my pistol out of my holster and
I'm standing on this rock and the bear
looks up and I like stick gun out. And
he like just looks at me like, okay.
And then walks off. It was
like, oh, that's pretty cool.
It's the guy hands me his rifle.
And he was like,
just in case it comes back and he's like,
do you want it to come back? He's like,
no, I don't know. So I make
this dying rabbit and I was like
charging it.
You know
there's a bear comes
charging in and throw the
gun up and as soon as they throw the gun
up, the bear wheels around, it goes off.
All right.
That was cool.
So we go back and hike up to the
four wheeler and I look and the bear,
what had done is it got into this dude's
pack and he left his pack on the four
wheeler toward the pack up and then
followed our tracks down to us looking for
food, you know, so I'm laughing at him
like, ah, you're packed, got ripped
off. I told you not to leave
it there. You need a idiot.
And he's kind of getting pissed like that.
I'm thinking this is funny.
And I get to my brand new four wheeler,
the bear toward the seed in half
and it was clawing and ripped.
It ripped so much that it tore the
key out four wheeler and stuff.
We couldn't find the four wheeler
key. And we ended up just, I mean,
we were like on our hands and knees with
flashlights where this damn key a long
ways away from where we started
and ended up finding the key.
But when I lived in Colorado,
a bear got into this lady's car,
opened up the door of her car and ate
her car. I mean the fucking eight.
They have pictures of it on the
website. They love, love their website.
They ate well. It wasn't even
leather. I think it was final. Really.
The bear ate the fucking dashboard.
The bear ate the dashboard.
Bear ate the seats to everything.
Just so mangled.
The inside of the car and new car,
they like that new car smell
like shit.
I had a buddy who was like a back
country ranger in the boundary waters
wilderness and Minnesota,
big ass million Acre wilderness.
There's latrines and all the campsites
and he'd have to go around and fix the
trains. Like every spring
after the shit came on frozen,
the bears would fucking crawl down in
there and eating human feces and all the
toilet in the blue water,
natural,
no blue water that they're just
like natural shit and water.
The bears would eat the shit black bears.
Jesus Christ.
It seems that they,
if they,
that's a weird thing too about watching
hunting shows is that if bears are
eating the right thing,
they're delicious. Yeah.
But if they're eating the wrong thing,
they're nasty. You are what you eat.
Literally. Literally when you
a, when you catch a bear and a,
or if you shoot a bear rather,
and the bear's been eating blueberries,
that's the most delicious. Oh, that's
what I've been told. It's fantastic.
Blueberry bear. It's fantastic. You
actually cut it open. You got the burger,
you can smell it.
You can see it in the blood.
You can see it in the fussy and the
fat. The fats blue, right? Dark.
It smells like it, Huh? Wow.
And it's delicious flesh of the
animal changes the color of the flesh.
The animal,
I guess I can't say conclusively.
I'd want to see another bear next to it.
And it didn't have it.
Maybe it's somewhat in our heads, but
certainly the fat. Absolutely. Yeah.
It looked like it looked like it was,
I would watch that one episode in Alaska.
Is that where you guys were?
And one we've done one in British Columbia
than it was feeding on blueberries
and one Alaska to wow. There are some
amazing animals out there though.
I saw a Golden Eagle go after,
um, some big horn sheep,
like swooping on dear size,
like the babies, you know.
And then I've also seen him knock a,
a mountain goat off a cliff.
You saw it like that was in
Montana. They this, so it, this one,
it didn't kill it, but what they'll
do is like, it knocked it off,
but then it got its feet and was okay.
But um, what they'll do is they'll, like,
they're the number one predators.
These mountain goes and they'll just grab
them on the back, hug him off a cliff,
they go down and eat them. It's
like, holy cow, that's an episode.
I've seen that it's made to do it.
The hang gliding. Yeah. Look at it.
Here it goes right here.
Look at this. There
you go. Look at this. Yeah, I've seen
that. Oh, that sounds a Himalayan.
Everything that is so gangster.
Look at it.
It just pulled it off the mountain
and just bash it against the rocks.
It's insane. I so crazy
this year. That out too.
They're so big.
That's kind of like a tool that's like
almost like as intelligent as using tools.
Yeah. You Birds Amaze me man. Like
Ravens. Have you seen this video?
There's these ravens that we'll figure
it out to drop nuts in front of like
traffic and then they go down when the
lights change and pick them up so the
cars break the nuts. Yeah, it's crazy.
We're seeing the one where the
raven figures out the use of tools,
not just as a primary tool,
but a secondary tool that you use a a
secondary tool to get the primary tool and
then use the primary tool to get meat out
of a, out of a puzzle. Really? Oh my God.
Pull it up. Oh, I got to savings. Raven's
solve complex puzzle. See if you can,
uh,
find it because it's,
it's one of those things that
shock the scientists when they,
uh, when they put it on, when
they put the experiment on,
you couldn't believe how fast these
ravens could figure it out. I mean,
it was unbelievable. Well, that's,
come on, let me see what I can find it.
Sorry.
Yep.
Yeah.
Let's say
yes,
this is one of them.
This is one of several.
So what they figured out is they
get this stick, look at this,
and they use the stick to get a
second stick. Yeah. They use it.
They figured out,
they figured it out instantly and then
they use that and now they get the second
sticks.
So he's got the second step.
Now use the second stick
to get something else.
Okay.
Hello.
Look who tried to get a third step.
Okay.
I mean, it's fucking mind
blowing, man. Look at that.
And he's got a third stick and then she
uses the third stick to get whatever the
fuck she was trying to get.
Okay.
She's trying to get some food. That's
awesome. And if she can't figure that out,
then she'll go and try a
fourth and a fifth dick. Look
at that. She got her food.
That's nuts man. And they figured
it out within seconds. I know.
I don't even think most people
would figure that out. Oh,
I would start with that.
I would start with that. Just fucking
ravens. Sneaky bastard. I had a steak, uh,
that was frozen and I was
trying to thought out,
so I said maybe we better if I put out
in the sun and I put it out in the sun in
my backyard for 30 seconds. And I came
back in a raven was eating it just gone.
I was like, no, he didn't eat all day,
but he picked like some pieces out of the
steak and I was like, you creepy prick.
Like you're spying on
me like you're watching.
He realized that I came out and
I put that stake down. It's like,
oh look at this stupid fuck you went
in the house. Woo. Like immediate,
like he's probably peering,
watching from the trees,
thinking about what I'm doing.
Like leave this dopey bitch.
Probably fallen you in your car every day.
I keep telling the story about an
octopus that I need to figure out if it's
legit and true or not,
but it's supposedly,
it was in a scientific laboratory and one
side of the room there was a tank with
octopus in it. The other side of the
room was a tank with fish in it. The
more things have lids on
them. Yeah. Octopus at night,
the fish kept disappearing and then like
what the fuck happened there? So the,
the octopus would take the lid off the
tank, crawl out, crawl across room,
take the lid off the other tank, grab a
fish, put the lid back on, crawl back,
put their own lid on.
Yes. Yeah. That was real. That is
real. It's amazing video. Yeah.
I don't know if there's a
video, there's a video. Well,
there's definitely a video of
octopus is climbing out. Look,
there's one right there.
An octopus walking on the
ground or crawling or whatever
the fuck you would call
that squirming on the ground and
they can move across the wall.
Do they have predators?
Anything? Kill Octopus,
you must kill sharks.
That's what's fucked up.
There was another video that
they took from an aquarium,
from a large aquarium and a,
they were trying to figure out why these
sharks were missing like what the fuck
is going on.
So they set up a camera and they were
worried when they introduced sharks that
the octopus who'd become food for the
sharks, but it's totally the opposite.
The sharks are swimming along and the
octopus looking at this out of nowhere,
leaps on this shark and
just fucking Jackson, look,
here's his shock. Like, well,
I'm the Buddha's
motherfucker in this tech.
Where do you is going to do both that
and this thing that looks like a rock is
just sitting there waiting
for his opportunity to fuck
up a shark and it's the
shark. It's too close. It leaps out
in nowhere and grabs a hold of him.
Check this out, swap us, get over here.
Wraps him up. Wow. Makes them
useless and just starts eat.
Yeah. Once those, I think once
shark, they have to keep moving.
Sharks always have to be swimming.
You know,
that occupancy just turns them upside
down and puts him in a submission hold
that sharks done.
Okay.
Isn't it an interesting how nature
balances itself out? It's like, yeah,
it makes it so sharks are awesome
and they have big giant teeth,
but let's throw a little monkey wrench
in and he can't sleep and you have to
keep moving. And if you pause, you die.
How about that is, you know, like people,
okay, you're going to be figuring
out cars and guns and all that,
but let's make your skin so that like
you could kinda pinch away through it.
You pulled parts out and that just
you bleed out and you just die
real easy. I have this, uh, this
unique experience this year I was out,
um, we were just looking
around and I see this,
these bear tracks in the
snow. So I'm like, okay.
So I'm actually out there just taking
pictures of these bear tracks as they,
they frozen in the ice. So it was like
a really cool look and track and uh,
I'm just like on road and,
but he's with me and he's like,
I get in the truck and he's like, there's
the bear. And I look up and you know,
cause I've been looking at, and it's
like 30, 40 feet away from the truck.
So I'm like, yeah, okay.
And it's like I've never seen like bears
always run away most like never seen a
bear tooth and walks off below the road.
I'm like,
there's something weird with this bear.
Right?
So we get out of the truck and I
look and it's like below the road,
so I sneak up and just start petting the
bear on the ass and my buddy's filming
it with his iPhone. Right. Whereas
I'm petting this, I've got,
I've got to get it from him, so I'm
petting this live bear. All right.
And just like, I'm just like, hey bear.
And just like talking to this bear.
But that story in your pocket.
I know,
well this happened this year and so I'm
petting this bear and then bear looks
back at me and he's like looking
at me and I'm like, there's like,
I thought it was like needed or something.
I'm not really sure what's going on
with this bear. His eyes are red,
the bears blind, she's blind
bear. He's like, never seen that.
So the bear like, it's like having trouble
moving around and we're thinking like,
I don't know, is this bear
been shot? Or like whatever.
So they were watching this bear and
I'm videoing it and the bear walks up,
he hits his head on a tree, walks into
circle, hits his head on the tree again.
100% blind. Yeah. So we're like these,
these two other guys that were with me
and both of them are vets and they're
like freaking out like, oh that bear
suffering. You know, what can we do?
You know? And it's like, as humans,
we, we feel sorry for things, you know,
we feel sorry for him,
but you know,
like looking at it like that Barry
didn't feel sorry for itself.
Is it just in nature? It was an old
bear and uh, you know, it's just,
that's what happens in bears get old.
They go blind and they starved to
death and die, you know. But I mean,
it was like crazy to see how this bear
was just like at the end it was probably
a 30 year old bear. Did you watch
the last episode of mediator?
Which, um, last Thursday, what was
it? Spring Bear? Just one where,
um, no, I didn't see that one.
Steve went bear hunting and
have a lock on a barren.
Just decided he didn't want to shoot
it and I just decided, uh, you know,
he did it twice. Two Times in the
episode is like, you know what, I don't,
I don't need to shoot this bear. Well,
here's the thing, people like that,
don't hunt. Don't get it necessarily.
Like, I love animals. You know,
it's like I,
it's almost hard to,
for me to believe how someone else that
doesn't spend as much time in nature
loves animals like I do because
I'm around them all the time.
I don't want to see these animals
disappears. Like people think, oh,
you're just out there to kill
these animals. No, that's
not it. Like, um, I think,
you know,
like hunters have words and then everybody
else has these words that don't mean
the same thing as us.
Like hunters of this word,
like trophy hunting or whatever where
they're looking for a large animal.
But for me like it doesn't mean
that I'm not eating it or whatever.
People have this different word
for it than I do. Like when I was,
when I said I was hunting for 30 days,
I could have killed probably a hundred
different deer and chose not to,
I did not kill it deer on that trip
and why I was looking for a big one,
but not because it was big,
because it was a challenge for me
to hunt the most mature animal.
Right.
And it made me be out there longer.
It put my skills instead of
against any deer against one deer.
And in that certain scenario I failed.
I was actually hunting
one particular year.
I ended up hunting that deer for three
years. I never got that deer. I never did.
You know, I probably put in
three months of time in scouting.
I saw him only twice in those three
months and was hunting one particular year
because it was huge.
And to me it was like the challenge
of it and I got to be in nature.
I mean I know more about those deer now.
I would sit there and watch them study
their patterns, like where they would go,
what their bachelor groups. We're just
like any nature channel, whatever.
And for me, I love those deer. Like I
don't want to see those deer disappear.
I don't want to see their
habitat be infringed upon.
I don't want to see like, you know,
it's not about killing these deer,
it's about being a part of
this system and prolonging it.
Like being out there hunting
and enjoying it and just,
you know,
doing my thing.
Yeah,
people have never experienced it.
Probably don't understand why it's so
fascinating and wonderful when you're out
there.
But I will suggest to those people to
keep an eye out for our British Columbia
grizzly episodes coming up because that
was an experience of us sitting on these
beautiful ridge tops watching grizzly
bears for almost two weeks of just like,
and that observation
is just like me saying,
it's just something like something
changes. How you feel about the animals,
how you feel about the land and how he
feel about your interaction out there.
It's, it's uh, it's pretty magical just to
be there. Well, when we were in Montana,
I felt that way about the sheep
because we weren't gonna hunt them,
but they were everywhere. We saw a lot
of them and it was, we sat many times,
we spent hours just sitting there watching
these sheep crawl up the side of this
mountain kind of freaking out.
Like, look at how they do that.
They're just crawling up this cliff.
The fuck are they doing that? It's,
and since we weren't hunting them,
they just became objects of wilderness
fascination, you know, they weren't,
it wasn't like the same like
quick heartbeat it thing
like, oh this is it here.
Do you ever do you know, there
wasn't any of that. It was just like,
look at these crazy fucks with
their giant balls. Remember,
seems like fucking John Steve,
there was a video pull the video up cause
I gotta take a leak of uh, Steve, uh,
talking about, uh, big horn sheep balls.
It's odd as a ut youtube channel where he,
he has a goal of sharing one of those
and then eating their balls like right
away, pull it up as if
he can. But yeah, just,
just being out there. And I remember
we found mountain line shit too.
That was pretty fascinating.
We for this big rope of shit with
deer hair in it and it was like, Ooh,
like this is out here too.
Huh? Do you have any draw for
bear to, to hunt the bear?
Does that attract you at all?
Uh, only one though. I would eat,
I would want a hundred grizzly
bear. Uh, unless I could eat it. I,
I've heard conflicting stories about
whether or not you can eat a grizzly bear,
you know. Um, I've watched a,
an episode of one show where they ate
bear stake was a brown bear and they said
it was good, which show it. Do you
know what show that was? Alaska.
The last frontier,
the guy shot a bear that was eating
their cows and a wound up cooking it and
eating it and had a little campfire and
is eating this the bear stake. What is,
did you have grizzly?
I've never eaten grizzly. No, I've never,
I mean I've never been grizzly hunting.
It just not something that I'd
done, you know, I really like,
I've never been like a bear hunter,
Predator hunter kind of guy. I mean, I, I,
I stick to a lot of a deer and elk and
stuff in New Zealand and stuff like that.
I mean, I've, I've hunted bears and I gave
you some bare Salami. Yeah. It's really,
I mean,
you'll eat it and you like anybody that
reads that and says that's not good.
Salamis crazy. Like it's
good. Yeah. So you like bare,
it's just not something you,
you go after a lot. Yeah, it's not, it's
not my thing. There's guys that like,
like it and hunt.
And then what's the difference between
going after a Predator and going after
something that's a game animal?
Does it get you sort of,
you feel like they're almost like
a kitten? Ah, sometimes. You know,
he's just kind of feel like that.
Like they're out there doing their thing.
Like you are sometimes, you know, I
mean, I don't have anything against it,
you know, it's not like I've bear hunted
and it's been fun and exciting. Um,
and I obviously eat everything I
shoot. So, um, if you killed the line,
I've killed the mountain line. That to
me in the past almost three years now,
huntin constantly with Steve has, was
the most exciting, just like balls out.
Fun Experience I've had is
chasing mountain lions in the,
we were in Arizona twice with dogs. I'd
never thought I would enjoy it. I've,
I was actually kind of opposed to it to
begin with. We never saw line whenever,
never killed the line,
never did anything.
But it was the most like if I got
fucking fired up. Isn't that crazy?
You didn't see a line. He didn't kill a
lion, but yet it was incredibly exciting.
It was. The dogs that go watching
hounds do their thing is just,
it's like adrenaline all day long and it's
just, it's a beautiful, it's beautiful.
These dogs are, you think, I wonder
what their vo two Max would be like.
Some of these dogs could run
for fucking ever, ever designed.
Do you have that video? Yeah.
Yeah. Play it because I got pissed.
We'll be right back folks.
The joint to the bone,
these are the parts of the animal that
hearkened back to the most original forms
of cooking it.
Chop it up and cook it.
You really don't get more primal
than a testicle. In my mind,
I would bring this down and share it
with the guys that I'm cooking for it,
but it's just never
going to go far enough.
There's inevitably going to be guys that
are real jealous and get a slice sauce
going to eat it myself.
So we kinda like to cook spouse.
So that's the do not look, look for one
that Joe Rogan is into with the she.
The only way I've ever cooked these
from game is in butter to do like butter
balls. Butternut. Basically.
I'm just like poach and
this thing and bought her
little red hots.
Okay.
Morocco. No, it's a, it was
in Montana. It was one of the,
it was one of the trailers for when Joe
and Brian came out to Montana first.
Oh, I had those ready. Yeah. One of those.
It's like it's something wax and poetic.
Yeah,
she,
there it
is.
She had the wrong one.
Big Horn right up there.
You go home and tell people what a bad
spot I took you to and you say four.
We did see a lot of big horns though.
What they're going to say is
something like, what kind of dumb ass?
Me Older in big Horn county.
You've never seen a scrolling.
I'd love to show you from
turn. Right. I'll look short.
It's like a,
it's like a church bell.
Look at church bell hanging down
between his legs. Wow. What a cool,
sweet.
Were you able to see that church?
It's impressive. It's huge.
Want to do all big warranty.
The first thing I'm going to do when I
kill him one and then punch my tag and
I'm to eat the contents of that side.
Just straight out.
Just raw. Just right
there like apples. Wow.
Feel called to do that.
I'm sitting on a cactus.
It looks so nice though. Right there.
He was so fucking cold as shit. So cold.
I had cactus in my legs for three months.
I did videos, a funny video of
Callen plucking my, uh, my legs.
That's also on the same channel.
Plucking a cactus out of my legs in front
of the fire. When I sat down the shoot,
that deer,
I must have got at least 50 or 60
cactus needles in my leg. It was crazy.
They last forever, but it wasn't a bad,
lasts forever. It was like a welcome sign.
Dan Toady off to the can. Yeah. The, um,
this is Brian Cowen,
my leg out and I mean he
must have pulled no bs,
at least 50 of those things.
How to me this way.
You look like I had like little zits
all over me for like a couple of weeks
afterwards.
It took a while for them to all pop
through the skin likes I'd be taking a
shower and I'd wash out feeling
like it felt like stubble,
but it was really just a cactus going.
They're just stuck inside of it.
Can feel that. And your face is level
two, your friend's ass, the pulling
will's out of his ass.
That's a real friend.
I have a new appreciation for his
glute and upper thigh development.
What was that movie where the guy sits
on a cactus and he thinks a rattlesnake?
I know buddies like, you know,
he's going to like suck the
venom out. Oh, that was, wasn't that
a Dan Akroyd movie or something? Gosh,
I can't remember. I don't remember.
Yeah, that's always the joke, right?
Suck the venom out. Can you actually
do that? Um, and it's not recommended.
It's not right now. I mean, I think
you can't actually do that. Yes.
Should the normal person, no,
it'd be a real extreme situation.
You'd prefer to like suck
it out with something else.
But, um, because of what Ha,
what can happen is then the venoms in
your mouth can travel your blood stream
pretty easily through your mouth if you
don't do it right. It is possible. But,
um, like what do you do? How do you
do it? What I would suggest is like,
say you're in the middle of nowhere.
You get bit by a rattlesnake. Um,
first thing you're going
to do is like put the area,
you don't want to blow your
heart. So, you know what I mean?
Just kind of keep it or like if it's in
your hand, your arm, your leg or whatever.
Um, I would maybe make like a
tourniquet, not super tight,
but you know, I mean a little
bit. And then you could uh,
use like some sterilize a knife
or something, cut it open. Um,
he like water in a metal
bottle or something. Um,
and then like if you have like a,
I kind of felt like this metal
canteen or something or hot water,
pour it into it and now gene bottle
like boiling water and then stick it up
against it on the outside. And as that
water cools, it creates like a suction.
It'll actually like suck
the blood and the venom out.
It's like a makeshift Suction Cup, you
know? So do you cut the wound open?
You come, you can cut. I don't know.
Sometimes they say don't do it sometimes,
you know, they say don't. But I
would, I mean people say you just,
you just dress it like a wound and
get, get what you need to go. Yeah.
We're talking like you can't get four.
You need to go then what?
He is not going to kill you Ralph.
Thanks. I'm not going to kill you,
but don't they do massive
damage to your tissue? Yeah.
My grandpa's the same grandpa, the crazy
grandpa. He's been bit three times.
Tell, tell him the story of
[inaudible] who died. This is the,
this is the craziest story. And you
know, some of these stories, you're like,
is this true?
But this is
been confirmed by like the
dude who this happened to. So
He's, he was, uh, you know,
he's a professional boxer and he
thought he was, you know, pretty quick.
I don't know what he'd
do. He like, I'm quick,
I'm going to snake, you know. So
he gets hammered by a rattlesnake.
I think he, he caught a rattlesnake.
He thought he killed it.
He put in a bucket and then it
bit him. So, and he was, I can't,
I don't remember where he's at. So He's,
he's, uh, gets bit by this rattlesnake.
So he's driving himself into the hospital.
He blacks out while he's driving,
runs through the front of a gas station,
convenience store, the whole
deal. And, uh, he breaks through,
the owner runs up,
he role opens the door.
My grandpa rolls out of the
truck holding a live rattlesnake.
There will be a movie made.
I like that.
It would be the craziest moving. You'd
be like, there's no way any of this.
And it's like,
he
was, that's what I'm getting at.
When you live like in this wildlife,
a lot of crazy things happen.
I mean,
he's just one of those guys that just
never, he just lived life, you know,
and he just,
Shit just always happened.
Like he had so many crazy I could go
on for days about just some of the most
unbelievable stories, you
know, like that is awesome.
He just kept it Florida the whole time.
He just, he lived on the edge, you know,
this was one of my favorite
stories is he went into a bar,
I think it was up in Virginia city. Nevada
is like a bike, you know, like anyways,
there's like this biker group that was
in there kind of taken over the bar and
kicking people out. Right? So he goes
out, him and his buddy were in there.
He tells the buddy, go
warm up the truck. The Guy,
he's a go warm up the truck
parking at that corner right there.
He's standing there and you help bikers
line up their motorcycles all along the
the edge.
He goes and kicks over one bicycle,
kicks him all over and domino fashion
tells a guy, walk in and say, Hey,
somebody kicked your your
bikes over out there.
And he's standing at the door and
as these dudes are running out,
he's one hit hitting.
I'm knocking them out.
He said he knocked about
four of a mountain.
I ran to the truck,
drove off.
I mean, he's, he's just
like a,
a mountain man cowboy
his whole life,
you know,
it's refreshing to know the crazy assholes
like that actually existed and did
live that life. And then they have
like grandkids like me, you know? Well,
all things considered, he
came out great. Exactly.
That's a very unusual thing
for a 28 year old guy. 28 yeah.
28 year old guy to live is most,
you know,
a giant chunk of your life to be in
the woods and living in the wilderness.
Yeah, it's definitely,
it's a one of those things.
I think like I graduated high
school and I knew what I,
I knew what I always loved and I just
like, I'm gonna make this in my life.
And people around how you knew that I'm
just going to start doing it, you know,
cause like I think after high school I
remember I actually graduated high school.
It's like a lot of college
credits. So I was like, man,
instead of go to school the fall semester
I'm going to travel around and hunt as
much as I can and then I'll write a book.
Okay. Did you, did you write a book? No,
still haven't wrote a book. I'm still
living it and I started it at all. I,
you know, I have, I've, I've started some
stuff because I've got like a lot of,
just like a lot of crazy
things have happened.
And so what I did was while
I went to college, every,
I would take six months off in the fall
and work as a guide and hunt and travel
and essentially do what I'm doing.
How far in advance are you booked for
guide stuff? Um, almost two years.
Two years? Yeah. Like
this year, next year.
Next year we, um, you know, we,
we've got, he, he's like 2015,
I guess we start booking now, you know,
and then New Zealand stuff is Kinda like,
you could pretty much come whenever
if you're, if you're like ready to go,
just go. So your, your guide stuff
is a lot of repeat businesses,
people that have been with you many,
many times and just book everything in
advance. Exactly. And then what happens,
because I've got so many like repeat guys,
you know,
I have other guides that worked for me.
It's like a fairly good size operation.
Um, and then uh, you know,
like repeats book every year.
But the new guys that want to end,
they've got to go like a year or two out.
So they get all their buddies
together and go year or two out.
And so you get kind of like backlog that
way. Yeah. Wow. That's wild. So that's,
that's actually a pretty fucking
stable business. Um, well,
yes and no because you got like a lot of,
at any given moment the regulations
could change and I'd be out of business,
you know, like, I mean, hunting is
very, very regulated and it should be,
I mean it's, if you do it right, it's
the purpose of it is for conservation.
And so yeah, I mean they're looking
at numbers and tags and all this.
And so at any moment where I do
my stuff could change. That's why,
that's why I started doing things
in New Zealand because every,
all the animals in New Zealand
are not supposed to be there.
So Environmental Sunamerica don't
want any animals that dead, you know,
environmental send New Zealand went all
the non native animals dead because they
eat the native grasses and they
aren't supposed to be there. This,
that and the other thing, you know, so
it's like there's no regulation. Yeah,
you guys killed the Canadian
goose with a high powered rifle.
I was just delicious. I bet
it was. But you know, I mean,
you think about it like Himalayan target
or just like they're one of the coolest
animals on the planet to me and they just,
the country they live in is so
rough and you know, New Zealand,
the southern Alps is almost
identical to the Himalayas.
Like that's where Sir Edmund Hillary
trained was on Mount Cook and New Zealand
for his first ascent to Everest.
I mean it's like we're,
me and Steve went hunting in that
episode that was in the Mount Cook area.
I mean,
we were hunting some of the roughest
mountains in the world and you're hunting
an animal that on its home range is
almost gone. And here there's like,
there's too many. It's overpopulated.
Wow. That is fascinating. Yeah.
Cool stories.
No predators shoot cars in New Zealand.
I don't know if we should tell a story.
I think Steve told us what happened.
Somebody shot a car. Yeah, no,
no, no, not so, okay. Well,
none of us, none of us
professionals. This is like
some other dude. We hired right
as a packer for that episode.
And after we crossed the river,
we sent him back,
hiked back to the vehicles to charge
batteries and he's sitting in the car like
fucking around with something and
apparently he comes back like we're like,
what happened to Ben? We're back in the
hut. Like Ben's like roomy. I need to have
no, he opens the door. We're
all in this little warming.
And is this the most sheepish face? Yeah,
I could imagine. Peaks, innocence. Remi,
can I talk to you? I was
like, do you didn't run the
truck out of diesel digit? No,
but I need to have a word. Okay,
so we go. So he's like, Hey,
I don't know to tell you this man is shot.
Your car
blew the fuel line.
The only line with a shotgun from inside.
He was sitting in the driver's seat.
He fired through the floor,
blew the fuel line and we had to tow
this truck. What was it like 30 miles,
30 miles down
like a river? No road. No road through.
We had to river crossings where the
truck is tied to the truck in front,
just dragging across the river where the
water is like flowing the drug. And so,
I mean, here's the thing, the dude was
Australian. I mean I liked the guy,
he's a friend,
but a Aussies don't have semiautomatic
weapons and he thought it would be try to
figure out how it works.
Oops.
In a truck with a loaded gun at he did.
Obviously it was an accident.
You didn't know it was loaded. It
was scary. I, you know, I was like,
you know,
I'm like when it comes to firearms
safety or any kind of safety like that,
I am the biggest stickler on the planet
because you don't get second chances
with that kind of stuff.
Like it's not something to mess around
with an any real like any hunter,
any gun owner knows that that's key.
Like you don't mess around with guns.
It's 100% the law,
you know, in, in my mind and my
friend's mind and everybody else's mind.
But he was by himself. He was just
kind of bored and messing around. Like,
what's this do? What's this button do
home? What's this do? Oh okay. Boom.
Oh yeah. I don't even know how the
fuck you could have done that. Uh Eh,
it makes no sense. I just play it
over and over again and you'll let me,
let me tell you like the Australian
jokes that were flying after that like oh
yeah. Ozzies are so good at shooting. They
can hit a truck on while it's running.
You know? Now you guys, uh,
in the New Zealand one you, you
haunted a tar, you hunted a,
what was the analyst? Shania. Is that the
same stuff that shammy cloth has made?
Yeah, that is, yeah. Why does it absorb
water like that? Like shammy cloth,
they used to clean up
yards. The leather, they,
it's just absorbing and
just soaks up the water.
And I think it has to do
with where they live. They,
their bodies are designed to soak up
that water and like wool, they're there.
Their hides a real woolly.
So wolves,
one of the only fabrics that
when it gets wet it retains,
its like our value of insulation.
So what they do is they get wet,
they expand in the,
their skin is like a wet suit.
You know how you get a wet suit,
you're like, it's freezing out,
but water gets inside and it keeps you
warm. They're kind of a stinky critter.
Those Shami, they got the gas
smell to them. I think Tara,
Tara definitely smell with both
of those things where it goes,
I was good cars. Good. Yeah,
Tarzan. One of my favorite animals.
But it's also like when
you go on a tar hunt,
it's a it in my opinion,
it's like it's an expedition.
You don't just like roll out and go, I'm
going to go shoot a target today. No,
you're like, you better be,
you're in the shit. You know?
I mean like when we got up there,
I was getting on these guys like we
have to leave before the sun. Yeah.
Before the shade hits this mountain.
Otherwise we sleep here
because you will die.
Because what happens is that the snow
mounts is within like an hour of the shade
hitting where the snow melts. It'll
turn to ice and you can't stop yourself.
And you'll just go off of 3000
foot cliff. Yeah, they're looking at it
right. Actually that's a tar right there.
So I don't think we have the shot
directly below those tar. Actually,
I don't know if that's a cross
that was across the river,
but where are we climbed up to?
Was literally probably a 1500 foot cliff.
Like just fucking drink. Fuck. It was,
well I remember that being a concern with
where you shot the animal because you
don't want to go off and fly off the
edge. Yeah, turn into hamburger. Exactly.
What happens when a tar flies
off a cliff drops 1500 feet.
Do you just leave it down there? Do you
go down and get it? You, you get it. I,
so this year for the sole hunters deal,
I,
I did this trip on my own and I crossed
the river. The river was so like crazy.
The water is flowing over the hood
and it's full inside the vehicle.
Like my ankles,
you fill the truck up with water to
cross because it keeps the weight down,
keeps it from floating and flipping.
So I've got a snorkel on my tracking.
Some of this I don't like couldn't
really cut because when you don't have a
camera guy, it's like fricking impossible
to cover everything. You know? He's like,
I really wish I would have covered that.
But when you're like I might die,
I'm not going to Dick around
with, you know, whatever.
So some of the good
crossing I didn't catch,
but I did get some of the other stuff
anyways. I mean you go across the river,
you're floating down the river and when
the water's going over and your heart is
like literally in your throat,
it's the scariest shit ever.
And then you get off and uh,
well you don't get off. But
I don't, I'm not quite, so the
cab of the vehicle is full? Yeah.
How are you breathing? I Dunno. Not
fully full like a where you'd be sitting.
So like where your feet,
you know what I mean? Yeah.
So I've got holes in the floor. So like
when when I do severe river crossings,
the level fills up. So then
like the, it like keeps,
keeps it down. So it was not full of air.
Did you have a special vehicle for them?
It's just a Toyota, just a
Toyota four runner. So diesel,
Toyota,
four runner.
And you put some quite a exhaust smart
goals so that it can be deep underwater
because otherwise where
the exhaust tips are,
if water gets in there and it stops,
the combustion is exactly,
if water gets in the engine, then it
doesn't work. It needs air to breathe.
So the snorkels up like right at
the top of the left window. Um,
and so what I,
you cross kind of like at a 45.
So you go up river and then you 45 down,
you know,
because that's the safest.
Um,
and then you just kind of
like are floating down driving
you here. I mean, you're,
it's grinding and waters over the hood
and everything and you're looking at your
window in the waters. Maybe halfway up
my nose just pull out like muddy water.
So then you cross and uh,
and then I,
I hiked up to this spot and uh, you
know, I'm Tara hunting and this,
that's like my favorite thing to do is
just an adventure every time. And uh,
I get up there and I,
I actually bow hunted up there like
a week before it was unsuccessful,
just really bad weather.
So I went back with a rifle and I
shoot this tar and I thought like,
oh, it looks good. Well fell
into a waterfall,
like the top of a waterfall.
So then I had to film myself scaling down,
climbing,
and then I hook it off the waterfall and
then go down in the next bit to where I
could cut it up and pack it out.
Wow.
And if you'd never seen a tar before,
they don't look like a real animal.
It looks like something out of Star Wars.
It's like a gorilla with horns. Yeah.
It's like a lion. Gorilla horns go. It's
crazy. They're cool. Yeah. They have very,
very bizarre here.
See if you can pull up one.
There might even have a,
they might even have one from the show.
There might be a video.
You guys have more videos online now.
And I understand that mediator is
now going to have a digital downloads
available. So you could, you could you
get down, I believe we're working on it.
It's not up yet. It's not something
you go right now and download.
But we're working,
we're getting there but trying to
get people to watch the show trying.
So there it is right there.
That's the tar. And that's uh,
one of the weird situations where they
weren't sure if it was a good place to
shoot it because it was right near that,
at the edge of that cliff.
It's tough to tell from there,
but
you would have done,
if anybody wants to check out the solo
hunter episodes from last year that that
waterfall bull will be on this season.
Um,
but last year if you go to
the solo hunters website,
I think it's a solo hundreds, tv.com. Um,
we've got every episode
up online right now.
Great. Great. So you can
just watch everything. Great
show. I've got Dvr, I got,
I don't know how many episodes on the Dvr,
but you have to go on a mind on this.
Check them all off. Great
show man. Because it's, it's
again a unique perspective.
Um, we were talking
about how Dan is so, uh,
into making sure that it doesn't look,
that mediator doesn't look like the
average hunting show. What's soul hunters?
It's like,
it's so unusual to see a guy wandering
through whether it's you or what was the
other guy's name? Tim Barnett.
Uh, I watched another one,
I watched two of them last night.
One with you in Africa,
another one with him shooting a Moose
and he was trying to drag this fucking
moose out of the water by itself.
And it was just like, God damn,
that thing is 1200 pounds.
This is fucking huge. And he's,
I mean he doesn't really a weak guy,
but I mean how the fuck are you going
to drag that thing out of the water?
It's like a lot of this like inches,
herbs,
hernia waiting to have.
Yeah.
That's the last thing you
want to have in Alaska too.
That's the nice thing, like if if you're
by yourself, you want them in the water,
a little boy and so he goes a long ways.
I was amazed that, I mean when we
were in Wisconsin, we shot that deer.
How hard it is to drag a deer.
Wasn't even a big deer.
What'd that deer way that I shot
130 pounds or something maybe.
Oh maybe a little more than that. I would
say, okay, let me go there. Maybe 150 no,
the other one, the one in Wisconsin,
so we're dragging it down. I'm like,
this is fucking exhausting. This
is a little, it is two of us.
There's two of us dragging this little
deer. I'm like, God damn fucking Mousse.
That's crazy. I think solo is
impressive in a lot of ways.
I think the camera works in pressing
it for them. If Remy wasn't the,
the hunter duty was I'd hire him to be
my camera man cause he's better. Most
people.
Well,
you also have an artistic perspective
on it that I thought was really unusual
and I didn't expect,
and watching the show,
we talked about macro shots and you know,
really close ups of putting this,
pulling arrows out of the ground and
seeing flowers and distance shot.
It's very artistic as well as being,
see, that's it. I, I liked doing
it because it's like I'm kind of,
I'm a creative guy. I like
designing things and being creative.
And so it's a way for me to like tell the
story of exactly what's happening with
no filters, nobody else's there. I'm
filming, it's my story. It's my world.
Like that's the closest way to get into
my brain, you know what I mean? Because,
and obviously like things get
edited too, you know? But I'm like,
I film what I like, you know, and so, and,
and I think like as it's grown and you'll
see more and more of that because I
like every bit of nature,
you know?
So I think you're going to see like an
adventure. You're going to see, you know,
plants and animals and all kinds.
So
who does the, um, the production, uh,
Tim does a production, like he edited,
said he does everything. So it's
a two man show. Yeah, exactly.
Sometimes a one man show
when it's his show, right?
Like it was him getting a moose.
He does the whole thing and he
designed this show. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's fucking great show again.
Another thing that's great about it is
this is zero redneck aspect to it. Yeah.
We try la can't believe. Here
we are again. Well, well man,
I'll tell you what, Alaska, I'll tell
you would, Alaska is a beautiful,
they're up for some awards to our show
or they should base is that for this
week? The shot show that'll be at shot
show this week. What is shot? Stand for?
Don't know. Something,
something, something and som
thing. He something hunting.
It's tactical and hunting.
Shooting, hunting, outdoor
trade. Guns. Sing. That's it.
Are we still going to try to do a
bunch of episodes of media this year?
I'll do four of them. I got
some propositions for you,
man. What do you want to do?
You say what you want to
do and I'll make it happen.
I want to do whatever we can do. Let's
do it. I'm not even interested in money.
I'm just what? I'm trying to have
fun. Well, at this point in my life,
this is what I want to do. I want to, I
like hunting. I do a lot of exciting shit.
I mean,
my whole life has been exciting shit from
martial arts to doing stand up comedy,
working for the UFC.
So I know what exciting shit is.
So when I get into hunting and
I'm fucking like, this is crazy.
This is even more exciting than I'm
used to be excited, you know? That's,
that's how exciting.
Let's do it.
You come up with your dream list of what
you want to do and the other thing that
I want to do is,
I don't know if it's a show,
I don't know if it's
just part of meat eater,
but I want to teach people how to hunt.
I want to do it like a how to thing
like first blood write a passage,
something just like taking people on
their first hunts. Explaining the skills.
I think people would absolutely love that.
I think it'd be entertained. I think,
well,
I think that was one of the
more interesting aspects
of the first episode that I
did with you guys.
One of the things that I've
found interesting is like
the first episode, boy,
when I was about to shoot that deer,
I was fucking tweaking.
My heart was pounding. I was, I was trying
to stay calm. It was so nerve wracking.
I had only shot a rifle
maybe five times before that.
Like literally I shot Steve's rifle
five times, two days before that,
you know, and this animals 200 yards
away and I'm trying to stay calm.
The second deer was like an
assassination. There was no, no heartbeat.
There was no weirdness.
There was no,
but I had shot 90 rounds the two days
before and 20 rounds of the day before of
of 300 win mag, so it was
just boom, boom, boom.
I was so locked in on
just shooting something.
See what's going to happen to you is
what happens like two most hunters is
you're going to do this for a while,
right? And you're going to be like,
what's next? And you're going to
go bow hunting and his elbow. It's,
it's a new world. Yeah. I'm sure. I
just got a blockchain. It's crazy.
I just picked up one last week.
I got a biotech experience.
I set up targets in my backyard. It's fun
to shoot to fuck. Yeah, it's exciting.
This is the discipline of archery.
Yeah. But I mean it's like the most,
when you're stocking animals,
like in being close, I mean,
it's the most Predator prey
primal thing you can do.
How much elk hunting do you do with bow
and Arrow? Oh, I mean, that's pretty much,
that's your thing. Well, I
personally am a bow hunter. Um,
I started like rifle hunting
again just because filming myself,
bow hunting was near
impossible in some cities
equations. And I still do it like
it's stupid, but um, I still do it.
But I mean my thing is bow hunting and,
and that's why like this,
this new Apex Predator show, I'm like
if I'm going to be hunting something,
it will be with a bow with my hands
or with a spear pretty much with very
specific, very specific learning
about like long distance.
So like Archer Fish Shit.
I mean where are,
we can talk about something
like [inaudible] and you
can even throw some input
because some of these we haven't
even decided on, but there is a,
a fish called an archer fish,
right?
And this fish is a master of ballistics.
So like this would be one of the rare
episodes where we use a rifle. Like we,
we look at this archer fish and this thing
will shoot a stream of water like six
feet or more and knock these little bugs
off and they are compensating for the
drop of the water.
And the reflection of the,
this is a crazy collection of everything.
They're like, they're the math,
they're like masters of ballistics.
And by the time they get to adult level,
they're one shot kills. Most of them look
at this. That's amazing. It's amazing
bidding and knocking birds off of
twigs and then they eat it. Yeah.
Nature is a motherfucker dude.
So
that's the like the cool,
that's why I'm so pumped about
this APEC show is because I just,
I love nature and I love what
it can teach us. You know,
I look at it like human hunters
are at the top of the food chain.
Like, but how did we get there? You
know? So this show, like this new show,
the Apex Predator show
is not me being an apex.
Better my quest to see how we
became an apex Predator. You know?
So I'm going to like look at every bit
of nature and in some way we've adapted.
I mean you look at like a simple moth
camouflage itself and then look at all
modern camouflage comes from the way
that we saw moths side or you know,
I mean there's like lions walk quietly.
And so we're,
we're thinking about doing
this episode where I,
I train hard and my feet and then go
in the Sonoran desert and hunt barefoot
like a mountain lion
would most excited for is,
is learning how a crocodile can stay
still and like submerge yourself onto it.
So the thing is that I'm so jealous
about Remy getting to do this,
that I have to do it along
with them because otherwise
I'd just do jealous about,
you got to get in the
water as well and do that.
We're going to submerge
underwater and then grab a pig.
Oh my God. You're going to
try to grab a pick that, yeah.
Just like your fingers son. Oh
my God. The waterhole. Just like,
like an alligator crocodile one. Wow.
Have you seen this video of this? Fuck,
there's this video of this Jaguar
swimming across then grabbing this Cayman.
We need to do that episode. Just like
Bam. I mean, that's, that's cool.
Yeah, that'd be careful
that you're not a Jaguar.
That's, that's the point though.
I mean, you know, it's like we,
we can look at nature and it's,
it's like one of these things,
it's like it can teach us so much and
I think it has in the past that we just
don't know about it.
You know?
I mean you look at like how wolves hunted
and then you look at these tribes that
hunt very similarly and you know, it's
like they had to have learned it somehow.
You know? And I think like looking
at nature, learning these things, um,
it just makes a,
it's like put us in the spot to where
we are where we don't have predators,
but dragging a pig into the
water seems fraught with peril.
Yeah, it does. The idea of
sneaking up on a pig in the water,
they're fucked. Terrible.
They smell everything too.
Right. That's, that's where,
I mean,
that's where like alligators
and crocodiles have the
advantage because they move,
they like the pigs don't even know that
they're there. They just like a log,
you know? And then they're grabbed by
surprise when he was cat and pulled in.
Boom.
Cats are such evil fucks.
They really are busy. So when you shot a
mountain line, did you eat it? Oh yeah.
Yeah. What does that taste like? Pork.
And it's like the closest wild animal.
The pork, even wild pork is in
his porky smell. Mine. Well,
how much of it do you eat? Eat the whole
layout. Yeah, you can eat the whole thing,
the legs, everything or
whatever. Those are the legs.
The legs are darker meat. Um, but I,
I was actually out Chickering last there
this weekend and this guy was telling
me that I'm some dude makes like I
don't some Chili Con Carne Aa in this
national festival and really secretly
uses mountain lion meat and wins every
time. Wow. I hate multiplied.
Once I had burgers,
a buddy brought me a couple of packages
and that same night I had a dream that I
was getting
and by a mountain. Right. Wow.
That's a weird thing.
So if it tastes that good,
why don't more people
hunting mountain lions?
It's not easy. I mean, incredibly
hard. The hardest thing to do. Yeah.
Yeah. It's specialized at the
most. I mean, what's more elusive?
There's probably something more elusive.
But in North America you don't,
nobody sees mountain lions. Naturally.
You don't, you didn't see them.
And if you do, it's like it's a
freaky moment. Yeah. So we're, I mean,
it is weird that a big cat that just
runs around killing things with its face
just
lives amongst us. You know, like
in North America, we're pretty,
I've spent a lot of time in
Africa and like in North America,
the animals disposition is fear of humans,
you know?
Whereas like in Africa,
there's so much competition that
large predators are more aggressive.
Um, so you know, like a mountain
line would be so lethal,
but they just are, they're
afraid, you know, they,
they don't see humans normally as food
unless it's like rare circumstance.
Mountain Lion. Yeah, yeah,
exactly. Or you know what I mean?
Like it's mostly like women and children
that get attacked by mountain lions.
You know? I mean, it's just one of those
things that they aren't that aggressive.
Even when they're like chased or whatever,
they try to be reclusive and don't
attack you. Like a wounded mount line is,
isn't first instinct to attack. It's,
which is like a wounded leopards.
First instinct is attack, you know,
which is completely different.
Yeah. Fuck cats dude. That's
all I had to say to fuck cats.
Cats creep me out.
They really do.
They creep me out because they
tried to catch it from behind.
They're sneaking up on you.
Is this,
that one that they spotted
in Hollywood is fucking cat.
They've spotted him in
the Hollywood hills.
They got him on game cameras and shit.
That's a big fucking cat to look at.
That thing. Yeah. Is He collared?
Yeah. He's collared. Yeah.
But they, these are recent pictures
that they've taken of him, uh,
in Griffith Park. Right where the
Hollywood sign is fucking blind.
Big One too big. 150 pounder.
What point is he like, mm,
that hiker looks good whenever he
gets running out of rabbits, cats,
rabbits, dogs, all that
kind of shit. Yeah.
It's an interesting thing when you know
you have encroaching cities and you
know, the, the,
the urban sprawl starts making its way
into these territories and you started
having to deal with the consequences of
a crossing the feeding grounds of these
animals. Yeah. It gets,
it gets weird, you know,
with bears it gets weird with cats.
Yeah.
It's like one of those,
it's one of those weird things that you
deal with because, you know, I've never,
I mean I kind of associate myself with,
I mean I sleep a lot on the ground or
wherever and it's like in that situation,
you know, you feel like
you're in their, so
it's like just part of it. But when
they come into a city it's like, oh,
in our world we can there. But
really it's like, no, he just,
we just can't stay away.
You know?
He's just moved our little
communities out there and we're,
we're putting this nice fluffy dinner out
in front of them every night. You know,
it's, it's hard for them to say now. Yeah.
One of them got shot in Santa
Monica a couple of years ago. Yeah,
I heard that 90 pound cat and
someone's backyard. Really? Yeah.
And they found it in the backyard and
they uh, they had to shoot it. Yeah.
Santa Monica. Man,
that's, that's, that's uh,
I mean it's had a walk through
a lot of streets to get there.
That's not the outskirts.
The other thing too is what's it,
I mean it has to be eating
pets or something because
it's only there if it has
food and it's, how long is it going to
survive? I mean like you look around,
it was like one dessert, eat
here or do homeless people.
I'm surprised like, you know,
people sleeping out at night.
If there is a cat and I don't know,
they'd probably smells so fucking bad.
The cats like I'm not going
to eat this guy, just cut me.
And maybe a bear would eat them
because bears eat human shit.
I think it's a lot of work for
a mountain lion to eat a human.
I think that's why they don't do it
really. A lot of work to catch us or to,
I dunno, I guess that's
just an assumption. I have
that here. Here's the thing,
those humans are the only
predators that stand, right?
Every animal on the planet knows
that the Human Predator profile,
you know, like, um, like when you're,
when you're stocking and deer or whatever,
trying to sneak out and
like get real close. Like Bo
distance, you don't stand up,
you crawl. Because sometimes I'll look
at you crawling and it's not a threat.
But if you stand up and give like that
profile, they know you're a predator.
Even like in Africa, you know,
if you, if you see aligning,
you let it see you're human profile,
they high tail it because they know that's
not right. That's, that's our predator.
You know? Well, that's also think, um,
there's a study recently that they, uh,
they published a report about it
in the Telegraph today. Actually,
I put it on my Twitter page.
That memories can be passed down to later
generations through genetic switches
that allow the offspring to inherit the
experience of their ancestors according
to new research.
That makes plain how phobias can develop.
So if you think about animals,
I mean every animal in North
America's ancestors got killed by us.
Every fucking deer, every,
every mountain line,
every bear they see as fuck that,
that,
that switch goes off that genetic switch.
And they just peel out of it the same
way everyone's afraid of big crazy teeth.
You know, even little kids that have never
experienced monsters before. Serpents,
snakes, spiders, all those.
And they think that that might be the
root of things like irrational ones like
Arachnophobia,
affiliate phobia,
fear of spiders and snakes and
then just heights, you know,
the weird ones so that like
they might have been, you know,
just a memory that stuck in the
DNA. Yeah. Cause that's always like,
you think about like the
snakes that have certain
colorations and animals
know not to touch him.
Then there's other animals that sim like
are similar to those colorations and
then don't get touched somewhere along
the line. Everything needs to know that.
Like that's poisonous.
Yeah. Yeah. No Shit.
What is, um, uh,
have you ever had a situation
where you were in a,
like a,
a place where you shot an animal and
you were trying to get it out of there,
but some predators were moving in
and making a play on the animal,
like wolves or anything along those lines?
Yeah, I had a client shoot a, um,
an elk once with a bow and a it ran off
and it took us a while to find it and
when we came up to it, um, like a
bear and claimed it and so it was a,
and then we'll kind of bear black
bear and the big black bear and uh,
it and it just scaring it off,
you know? And it didn't really,
didn't really do anything.
But most of the time human
scent is a pretty big deterrent.
Animals don't like the way we smell, you
know, if you can get your center around,
they're gone. That's
interesting. Generally speaking,
and this bear this fall
actually attract us by scent.
Oh. But generally I can get you in
that and they'll, they'll go away.
Now when you go bow hunting, do you
bring a gun or anything just in case? Uh,
no I don't. And uh, that's like my, maybe
you just like I were talking earlier,
just like getting complacent.
I, I forgo a lot of safety nets.
Just the travel light. Yeah. You know,
I forgo like a lot of things
like in a lot of trips, man,
I won't even bring enough food.
Yeah, I saw that. Yeah, that was,
I was next question was going to ask you,
you tried to just shoot things and
eat them all the way? Yeah. Yeah.
I mean like it's kind of like
one of those things for me,
it's like part of the adventure part of
the trip and it's also like a personal
experience. Um, I mean there is
one hunting. I mean, you know,
I like mention it like on say it was a
solo hundred whatever, I'll mention it,
but I don't play it up in the show
because it's like, I don't know,
I mean it's almost like too dramatic and
playing things up that don't make any
sense to most people.
So it's just my personal thing.
Like there was one deer hunt.
We're literally,
I s I was starving and I was going
probably 3000 vertical or more a day,
lots of miles over
12,000 feet in elevation.
I mean my body was eating
itself and it was really weird.
I mean yeah was something weird to talk
about but like there was nothing left.
It was just like you had
to go to the bathroom.
It was just like mucus coming
out, you know, just like white.
It's like spit it just be like
spitting like no, just water, nothing,
absolutely nothing. And you know,
you feel the ill effects of it.
But for me it's like okay that's part
of it. Like hunting, like you're hungry.
And I think for apex we're going to do it.
I want to do a hunt where um,
cause cause we hunted, we, each episode
we're setting up like an experiment.
So there's a lot of hunt science involves
a lot of science involved. And uh,
so what I'm going to do is
do this experiment where
I like fast for three days
and then do a blind before,
like I'm full.
I go into a room and then see how
I can pick up since, you know,
like maybe have like three rooms,
five
rooms, one has like an animal sent
another food sent to blank, you know,
see if I can see it or I
mean smell it. And then, um,
and then like starve
myself for three days,
which really if like for hunger
isn't that long. And then, um,
and then see if I can smell things.
I did an article a while,
probably two years ago. And, uh, like
as we get hungry, our olfactory senses,
which are our first sense is to develop
our sense of smell is like our first one.
And as we get hungry, we start noticing
different things. And there's like,
when you're hungry, you're actually
like doing more exploratory sniffing.
He was like smelling the air because it's
our first, it's, it's funny, it's like,
that's our first sent to finding food
because we can find the invisible.
That totally makes sense.
And it also makes sense the same way
sex feels better when you haven't gotten
laid in awhile and you're like, oh this
is great, but if you fucking twice a day,
every day, like all right,
here we go again. You know,
like stuff my face with another fucking
cheeseburger or I'm starving to death
and I smell something amazing. You know
someone's got a pot roast in the oven.
Oh my God, I haven't eaten in days.
Holy Shit. This smells good. Yeah,
probably do. That's one of the things I
think that people enjoy about fasting,
that they don't really talk about it.
Yeah.
It gives your digestive system a break,
but it also makes you like
really appreciate the food
for shirts and can finally
eat the same thing with hunting or hiking
all day. Why to food tastes so good.
It's just cause when you burn calories,
you need calories and your
body's just like, yeah, that's
a, that's a big one. The,
the burning calories, like you want to
stuff your fucking face when you get back.
You can't eat enough. No.
And fats, you want fats.
That's the weird things. You find
your body craving fat, animal fat,
your body wants what it needs,
you know,
and I think that's going to be a part
of the of it too is I really think that
that experiment would go well.
Like we'll,
I'll smell things that I
wouldn't smell when I'm full.
And then also then we'll go,
I'll like starve myself and then go
hunting because a large population of
predators actually don't hunt
until they're starving. Wow. Yeah.
Like a wolf. The feast or famine, they
just go shoulder gorged starved gorge.
It's like, it's a really
weird deal. But you know,
they hunt better when they're hungry.
I know people can hunt wolves now.
Does anybody eat wolf?
Apparently.
I mean Steve was telling me and I've
read and like some people say it's like
there is a few explorers back in the
day. They were like, it's the best thing.
I think it was Steffenson Steffenson yeah,
yeah. That this is exactly what, what,
what was the best?
Maybe cause you fucking hate them because
they're trying to kill you and you
killed them and then you get to eat them.
Well,
my guess is he's pretty fucking hungry
when he hit that wall. Pretty good.
Wow. Wolf would be the imagine if it was
unbelievably delicious. I don't know.
It's not logical,
but because they're eating other meats,
generally the sower mountain lions
eat the mountain lion legs.
He the loins mostly I don't think don't
eat the legs. You can but you don't.
I think you know, you make it into
like ground some kind of Mexican dish.
Everything tastes good.
You know why?
Why would need to like see
the too too muscular? Is that
what it is? I think so. And just gave me,
so the loin meaning the muscle
that covers the spine area,
the extra backstrap that's
the softest for some reason.
Yeah,
it's the most tender.
It's still like the largest piece of
meat without any connective tissues or
ligaments, stuff like that, you know,
which make it chewy or whatever
and muscles get worked or like,
like I think of a chicken,
it's like dark meat,
so you have a difference in your aerobic
and anaerobic muscles and that like the
amount of blood and oxygen that's put in
there in the amount of use changes like
the flavor and in meats.
That's why a lot of people like love beef,
but if you think about the
way those animals are there,
they were like putting these
lots where they don't move in.
Their muscles aren't real.
I mean it's like they tried to make
them all better tasting by not working.
Yeah. Isn't that fascinating? Like I
think Coby beef tastes gross. Terrible.
I don't like it.
I I you know,
someone at a restaurant told me that
I have to try it. It's amazing that,
you know,
told me the whole process.
They massage this animal and then they
give it beer and all this different stuff
to make it okay. It was
a greasy mess. Yeah.
It was just like dance t greasy disease.
It was like eating an alcoholic.
People. People always ask me like, what's
the weirdest thing you've ever eaten?
You know, and I've, I've been like
coyote who knows what you know?
I've eaten like pretty much most weird
species on the planet raw, you know?
And I'm like thinking about it.
I'm like Slim Jim.
Yeah,
that's great.
It's all Dixon Dixon cow falls.
Yeah.
Slim Jims are fucking all that
mystery weird shit. We do.
We package things in a tube forms.
What strange thing we always
make it look like dicks. No,
never looks like a Frisbee.
We turn them into Dick's.
Is it easy to just roll it?
What's the reason to get mystery
meat and Dick Forum all about?
It's an old practice though, people than
making sausages for hundreds of years.
Why we you make sausage and you're like,
this is the most ridiculous
thing I've ever done. Do you,
when you make venison sausage, do you
add pork fat to it? Um, sometimes, yeah.
I think like
if I, it's something I'm
going to give out or whatever.
I had pork fat because it gives
it that extra consistency.
A lot of times on my ground meat. I don't
add anything. I just like it how it is.
Yeah. This, uh, this
trip, last trip we uh,
had meat sent to a processor,
a butcher,
and he turned it into sausage and a bunch
of different things and they added fat
to it. But this trip, uh,
we did it ourselves and I didn't add
anything to the ground venison and I just
cook it with grass fed butter
and garlic salt, just cook it.
We leave it fairly rare and it's unfucking
believably delicious. It's so good.
I cook up some Kale and a, and then
I, that's like my favorite new meal,
ground venison and Kale.
It's fucking sanely good plus tomatoes.
That's my like favorite meal of all time.
It's like I can eat that twice a day,
every day, especially if
you grow your own. I've,
I've been doing that lately
to growing my own cauliflower,
Broccoli, tomatoes, and my ultimate goal
is to be responsible for all my food,
all my vegetables and all
and all meat game meat.
Have you noticed how much more you care
about that food too? It's like insane.
Like you just think about like you take,
like when I take an elk stake out or
whatever, I like take it out. I like,
I like treat it like a baby,
you know what I mean?
He like d frost that you like
marinate it. You like Miss, you know?
It was like even with like a tomato
you grow, you like pick it gently,
like carry it inside and Wa you know,
and he's like the ones you
get from the grocery store,
you just throw on the counter in a
bag. Like it doesn't mean shit. Yeah.
The meaning behind our food is definitely
something that we've lost in our
transition from hunter gatherers to
this weird sort of agricultural based
society and not even agriculture where
you're connected to the agriculture.
We just go to a place given paper and
they give you the fruits of their labor.
It's weird. Yeah. Yeah. You put it really
well. I think this last time in Wisconsin,
just about the weirdness we have here
in this country about about just meat in
general. The consumption is consumption
of it. See, it's weird. It's, it's,
there's a disconnect that goes quite deep
that, uh, you know, we're looking at it.
People are looking at, I think
it's being recognized, but it's,
it's pretty fun to think about like,
the people that live a
long time on this planet,
they're all people that eat food from
where they're at. You know what I mean?
There's just something to be said for
people that eat things that are from where
they are.
You know,
it's like if you have deer
in your backyard and things
that you can grow around
there, there's just something to be said
for having that kind of diet. You know,
I think it's like weird for humans to eat
a orange from South America anytime of
the year, you know? I don't
know. Well, I think it's,
I would love to see some sort of a study
on the nutritional aspects of wild game
over or over beef and what,
what they are. I mean,
I know you said that the elk has very
low cholesterol and comparison to Evan
chicken per gram. Well elks,
um, even more so than venison,
but um, or deer, a lot of people call it
venison or whatever, but um, yeah, the,
the amount of protein per
gram is like double in, uh,
in game meat as well. Really? Yeah. So
you get more protein, less cholesterol,
less fat.
Because think about it while the animal's
store their fat on the outside of
their muscle because it needs to be
readily accessible so they burn it the
quickest. Whereas like meat is not
supposed to have fat inside of it.
It's not supposed to be marbled.
That's something that we've created.
It's something that we created by
feeding them this high protein,
corn and everything and
not letting them move.
So when you eat something where the fat's
inside, that's completely unnatural.
I mean, you could get any, any
animal marbled like that if you,
if you treat him the same way,
but because game animals
keep the fat on the outside,
there's relatively zero fat inside the
meat itself because it just doesn't make
sense because they would need to burn
it and they can't access it as quickly.
So that's why like, and then
if you look at it, well,
if it's not fat mixed in there, what
is it? What's protein? Pure protein.
So for the same amount
of steak that you have for
beef and verse wild game,
you're gonna have more protein,
less cholesterol, less fat.
Do you ever worry that
someday that because of the,
the negative attitudes about hunting
and the sort of disconnect that we
experience now as opposed to in the past,
just, you know, a hundred years ago,
this is a massive disconnect
between now and then.
Do you ever worry that there's gonna
come a day where they will stop hunting?
Um, yeah. I mean of course you
worry about that, you know,
but you think about it and maybe I think
that there'll be a lot of resurgence of
certain things when we kind of,
people would start saying, hey,
this is really messed up.
This is really messy. I mean,
everything in our society
changes at some point, you know?
And for better or worse,
I mean,
governments are always changing and the
ideas behind things are always changing.
And you look at like our
food and at some point,
I mean you're really starting to
see it now where people are like,
what exactly am I putting into my body?
You know,
it's kind of like beef.
Actually nobody ate beef.
Everybody like the original Americans
when beef was around because they would,
they would drive the cattle from
Texas north before the rail lines.
And so beef was the game must meet
on the planet. Nobody likes beef.
And it wasn't until the railcars where
they could ship them up and then put them
in feed lots that people started
liking beef over game meat.
So I think that then people would be like,
well why do we actually like this,
this, you know? And if,
if people really understood what
they're eating and you know,
like the benefits of other things,
I think that there's popularity in that.
But on the flip side,
like is as you've experienced,
hunting isn't one of those things like,
oh,
I'm just going to go out and
go hunting. You know? I mean,
you need somebody to show you. It's
very, it's like a hard thing to do.
And a lot of people don't
realize that like, uh, you know,
you might hear this person is
against hunting. Be like, oh,
how hard is it to go out and kill
something with a rifle? You're like, well,
to do it the way I do it, like as a
true Predator out in the mountains,
hunting and stalking. And it's not that
easy as you've seen. I mean, it could be,
there are a lot of times you
come back with nothing, you know?
Oh,
no doubt.
And that's one of the things that I really
appreciate about both meet eater and
solo hunters is that you guys show
unsuccessful hunts. Yeah. And you know,
and it's not like you're like all
depressed and it's like, look, you know,
this is a part of it. It's hunting. It's
not killing. You know, it's not that,
it's not like you're going to the Penn
finding a cow that you enjoy and shooting
in the head.
You're,
you're going out there into its world
and you may or may not be successful.
And there's a lot of factors
there that those factors, the,
the lack of success on occasional hunts,
make the successful
hunts feel even better.
Yup.
What a better way to end it. Perfect.
So the show is called Apex Predator. Um,
you guys are in the middle of negotiation
and you'll keep us updated on what it
is.
Let us know who picks it up or what winds
up happening will promote the fuck out
of that. Uh, Daniel Dodi on
Twitter. Right. And do you have a,
apparently I do.
Have you ever used it?
I will. Now we me Warren
at Remy Warren. Okay.
R. R. E. M. I. N. A. W. A. R. R. E. N. N.
Of course a meat eater. TV is the
meat eater. Twitter, Steve Rinella.
We'll be here with us on Friday and we're
going to talk some more with him about
probably a lot of [inaudible]
same subjects. And we're
also going to go hunting.
Steve and I are going out this
weekend, so, uh, thank you.
Thank you to everybody tuning in. Thanks
to our sponsors, Doctor Rick Strassman.
Unfortunately had to cancel. Um, uh,
we'll try to get them back again.
He's in the middle of publishing a book
though. So this week you won't be on,
but we got a lot of people on this week.
It should be a lot of fun. A lot of,
a lot of people including Steve Rinella.
A Dom Irrera is going to be on tomorrow.
Uh, Brian Denny, we've got a lot of people
coming up. Lots of fun ladies, gentlemen.
So thank you. Thanks for everybody
that came out to Phoenix this weekend.
Tom Skirt and I had a great fucking
time. It was a lot of fun. And uh,
thanks to our sponsors.
Thanks to squarespace.com
go to squarespace.com and
use the code word Joe and
the number one and save yourself some
cash money. Ladies and gentlemen,
what exam exactly do you say? Um,
I'll pull it up. Hold on a second.
I thought I had my sponsor copy
in front of them. I got it.
A squarespace.com offer code is Joe and
the number one and save yourself 10%.
And also,
uh,
use the code word or use the Hashtag j r
e Squarespace and tweet all of your new
website designs that you've
created through Squarespace and uh,
do it by January 17th and four of the
winners will receive a free year of
Squarespace and a bunch of other swag.
And we're also brought to you by Lumosity.
Go to lumosity.com forward slash Joe,
that's lumosity.com forward
slash Joe and check it out.
It is literally like a gym for your brain.
I enjoy it.
I enjoy the gains and uh,
I think it keeps my brain fresh.
Speaking of fresh Razo, brought to
you by [inaudible] dot com it's o,
n n I t use the code word Rogan and
save 10% off any and all supplements.
All right, we will see you
tomorrow to podcast tomorrow. Um,
one of them will be in the a uh,
actually noon with a dom Irrera
and the other one with uh,
Brian dunning and that is at 3:00 PM.
He is a skeptic and a very
intelligent guy. We should a lab,
a lot of fun on that one. Then
Brunellos on Friday. All right.
Until then we'll see you a big kiss.
Wow.
Okay.
Yeah.